[Music]
[Music]
what's going on everyone welcome on in
to the id
at xbox showcase
foreign
shhh
you have shown an aptitude for applying
lethal solutions to conflicted
situations
we wish to test your abilities by giving
you a special assignment
success and you'll be given a chance at
earning your freedom
what the hell are you trying to kill me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right void train i see what you're
doing there uh
which rain looked really cool that last
one that we just saw i was getting like
outer wilds meets abduction kind of vibe
from that
uh brianna were there any of those
trailers that particularly jumped out at
you
yeah i mean i was kind of looking at i
think it was called wild at heart
it almost reminded me of don't starve a
little bit it looks like you're trapped
in the forest maybe with a friend
i'm very excited i mean xbox came out of
the gate
swinging with this showcase i am beyond
excited to see what's next up oh yeah um
i i
the first one that they showed that exo
mecca uh game i saw some people in chat
were like
is this like a mech battle
titanfall-esque thing i mean the cool
news is that a lot of these trailers
that we just saw if not all of them i
might be mistaken on this but uh a lot
of them
said coming 2021 so those are games we
can expect this year
um like i said i'm a big fan of indie
games i'm a big fan of the id at xbox
program which we'll get into
a little bit later about how the
specifics of the program work
but bringing all these indie games to
light is what it's all about so
omni we got to see a trailer for and
i've gotten to play a very early build
of that and it is so adorable
so we've got a lot of fun stuff uh
coming up and a lot of fun stuff here
that we've seen already it's been
awesome
brianna do you play a lot of indie games
on your twitch channel
i do i kind of switch off i mean my
favorite thing about indie games
honestly
is the art style i am such a sucker for
not only good graphics but just
visually appeasing games and i feel like
with indie games you get
so much of that and also by the way i do
want to remind the twitch
chat at home please sound off what game
did you see from that last trailer
are you excited about i would love to
hear it and you never know your comic
can end up right here
on the big screen yes i see uh bert
toast
burnt toast tj or burnt toast j in chat
says so great to see such wonderful
support for indies yes 100
yes um so yeah that was exo mecco i
believe ascent was the name of the
second one omni the wild at heart
and uh void train there at the end
really really cool oh yes i am excited
oh i love that word
okay so here we go here was exo mecca i
believe is what this one was called
again and this is the one that some
people were
comparing to titanfall i don't know my
first thought when i saw those mechs i
saw kind of the circular light design in
the center of their chest and i was like
positive
uh now not all of them have that but
this is reminding me of every great mech
battle
that i know and look at that we have
underwater i think i saw a grapple hook
there it is a grapple hook mechanic in
this
is this the type of game you think you
could see yourself jumping into
see i'm a little funny when i play games
i'm not a huge
fan of first person shooter type games
however
the graphics are very very nice i mean
and it looks like it's action-packed
there's so much going on like you said
you're able to go underwater
it looks like you were shooting at a
helicopter in the last clip that we
saw this looks pretty good i might have
to give it a try
i love the folks in chat right now that
are so hyped for the among us segments
coming up that they're just saying
of course this trailer looks so sus i
get it i get it but yeah that was uh
just
one of the so that was one two three
four five
trailers already shown and like we said
we've got a packed show for you today so
lots and lots of trailers coming up but
i thought exo mecca
looked super super cool um uh that
cyberpunk
one i think it was called ascent i think
the the twitter handle oh
that's right um that cyberpunk one felt
very like
shadowrun-esque to me in a good way and
i mean i don't know about you but i
played through cyberpunk
2077 and it didn't quite scratch the
cyberpunk itch in the way that i was
hoping for
so maybe this game totally could maybe
maybe okay
fair enough he just looks stunningly
beautiful is omni more the type of game
you would traditionally stream
yeah i would kind of look more towards
omni like i was saying before
wild of heart is definitely something
that
captivated me and caught my eye as soon
as i saw it so
i am very excited and i like that you
said that about that cyberpunk feel
because
you know some people are kind of looking
for something in that genre if
cyberpunk didn't exactly do it for them
so i'm excited about these
yeah i see uh mundane in chat says
mundane salad says shadowrun is greater
than cyberpunk
you know what you said it not me um but
i don't
entirely disagree with you very spicy
very spicy
steak on there today um
so folks like i said that was just a
snippet of some of the fun that we have
for you today but let's bring in
our first guest so our first guest on
today's show is the senior director
of the id at xbox program which has been
helping
independent developers self-publish
their games on microsoft's xbox consoles
for the last seven years and if you're
wondering what types of games id and
xbox are working on right now that will
be coming soon to a console near you
well here's a sneak peek
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chris thank you so much for
joining us how are you feeling today
good thanks yeah thanks for having me of
course
of course now for everyone at home
watching that aren't already familiar
with the idea
xbox program can you explain a little
bit about how that works
yeah sure so basically we're a program
at microsoft that enables independent
developers to self-publish their games
so they
come to xbox.com id they sign up they
tell us what kind of game they're making
and we send them dev kits they start
development
they make the game and then we uh
they're they're the publisher we try and
help amplify the promotion with things
like um
what's happening today and then the
games come out people play them
everybody's happy it's awesome
it is awesome i personally love indie
games and i think we've seen
indie games have this uh not even not
even resurgence but kind of like just
been being brought
more into the public eye in the last
decade or so
um and it makes it a little bit hard for
some people to kind of qualify
what is indeed an indie game so i want
to ask you chris what are indie games
all about
in your mind well that's actually one
thing we do in the program is we don't
try and define it
in fact i used to have a like a buster
on the outside of my
office that said indy with a little
buster through it because i was like you
know what like we're
i'm old and i spent the 90s as a punk
rocker arguing about what was punk and
what wasn't punk
and like we don't need to do that you
know what i mean it's some
it to me an independent game is really
all about creative control
if a developer has creative control you
know they have that independence
but you know we have folks in the
program who are single individuals you
know one woman
one man making a game we have studios in
the program that are
hundreds of people making a game so we
don't stress about it like
our focus is just on helping people get
their games onto xbox
helping get them great and then making
sure that players get to see them and
have a good time
cool that is incredible now chris i know
i'm sure there are so many amazing
moments that you were able to experience
throughout your seven years with the
program
but if you could pick one what would be
your
proudest accomplishment uh you know what
i can't i can't
the thing that like really gets both me
and the the whole team on id
um going is really like when we're able
to help a developer
like a lot of times especially first
game like ship that first game
and that that like always feels great or
when we're able to work with developers
from like
all over the world like we work with
developers in more than 100 countries on
every single continent except antarctica
is really cool so it's
it's hard to pick up a proud moment but
maybe my
favorite moment was um i think it was e3
i can't remember which year and um it
was right when we unveiled like the full
cuphead trailer
and i had seen the trailer i knew how
good it was and i'm on stage i got the
privilege of introducing the the
moldenhauers
and um the lights go on the molded
mdhr logo comes up on what at the time
was the largest 4k
screen in existence and i knew
everybody's socks were about to get
blown off and just standing there in the
dark
on the stage looking up at the studio
mdhr logo
was like i still get goosebumps i have
goosebumps right now talking about it it
was like
it was such a cool moment it's such a
cool moment for them and such a cool
moment for everybody who likes um
to be you know just excited by game so
to me that's like it's one of my
favorite moments of my career
i remember that moment i remember when
cuphead was first unveiled at e3
and everyone was like what is this
um and and it delivered i mean combat's
a fantastic game um
so what excites you right now like
what's the most exciting thing about the
indie game
scene in 2021 in your opinion just a
variety i mean we just saw on that
trailer and and all through today
we're just gonna see so much variety of
games
and and you know it it used to be that i
think when people heard the word indie
game
there was a song of like okay side
scrolling pixel art and there's still a
lot of great side-scrolling pixel art
games
but there's everything from first person
shooters to you know every genre under
the sun
new genres nobody's ever thought of
before and
to me what's so exciting is these games
come from everywhere
right i think there's a game i don't
want to give it away maybe it's a reveal
but there's a game we're going to see in
a little bit
from um two devs in the philippines it's
really really neat
uh desperately which was just in the
trailer an airport for aliens run by
dogs where you
like go around and interact with like
clip art
dogs that are rotating um like those are
all super cool and then you have games
that just come out of nowhere
not really out of nowhere but like
shotgun farmers which is a game that uh
launched on xbox um and and
was from one person and dominated the
sales charts on xbox for like
a couple weeks it was like the number
one game on xbox and that is just
so cool that the world today like
enables that kind of thing to happen so
that's what i love i just love the
variety
i'm always amazed learning at some of
the
sizes of some of these development
companies
does it blow your mind what smaller
indie teams are able to
create and produce in comparison to aaa
companies
absolutely i mean we've seen like such
great
i think we just call it like
democratization of development with the
rise of engines like unreal and
unity and game maker um it really is now
enabled
um the focus you know games is still
incredibly amount of hard work to make
but the focus is on like how good my
idea is how good my story is like
developers are no longer gated by the
technology as much as they were
10 and 15 years ago so that's that's
awesome to see and it's it's also been
awesome to see how things like
game pass um have enabled um
so many players to experience so many
games it's been
it's just really really cool yeah it is
super cool and i
i for one love being able to jump on
game pass and try something completely
new
uh because it's worked into that program
and we will definitely see
games today in the id and xbox program
that are available on game pass
um but not all of them that we'll show
today are i don't think isn't that
correct chris
it's summer that's right yeah it's a
variety you know games like um you know
i'm trying to think like off the top of
my head genesis no warship recently that
was a game pass game but shotgun farmers
not a game pass game you know and and
there's
a huge amount of variety that's in game
pass which is fantastic and there's a
huge amount of variety of games that are
you know not in game fast so
it's it's it's just great like uh
there's just a
tons to play um and that makes us feel
really good
absolutely uh where do you think that
indie games are headed
next so say in the next decade or two uh
that is a great question and and and the
the answer i'm gonna
give is that i have no idea but i mean
that in the best possible way
you know if you would ask me when we
started id if somebody if somebody was
gonna come up with
a game where you shoot shotguns and when
you miss the shot
a new shotgun grows out of the ground i
never would have guessed that
if you would ask me is somebody gonna
make like a game that's hand animated
1930s animation
i never you know i never would have
guessed that and so
what i love about indie games is they're
always surprising us they're always
giving us something new
and so when i say i have no idea what
we're going to see in 10 years like
that's what excites me like if i knew it
was going to happen i might not be as
excited so so yeah i think in the best
possible way
i have no idea
that's really interesting you say that i
am kind of
curious with these next generation
consoles that have just released very
recently
how is that transition been has it been
kind of difficult
or no not really we've been seeding uh
xbox series x and xbox series s's to our
developers for a while
and we've been really excited to see how
many independent developers are
supporting features like smart delivery
where you
you might have an xbox one today and you
buy the game and then when you get your
xbox series s or your xbox series x
you just download the updated version of
it at no additional cost
um and and you know independent
developers are always surprising us
and so um next-gen features whether it's
ray tracing or smart delivery
folks are taking advantage of them in
really interesting ways and
um so it's been um it's been exciting
it's been exciting to see the games but
one thing that we're proud of is that
the transition itself for developers has
been
boring and i mean that again in the best
possible way that
you know they get this new system and
they can start taking advantage of the
power of it but they don't have to
get a phd to figure out how to use it
and so um you know that that is kind of
always our goal to make it as easy as
possible to ship
so that the focus for developers can be
on their game
on taking advantage of the hardware not
like fighting against the hardware and
just being excited they got something to
run
yeah in that context in particular
boring is fantastic for the independent
i'm sure
um so speaking of indie devs what advice
would you give to any dev teams out
there who might be watching
who would want to apply to id at xbox
yeah just reach out um it's a xbox.com
id um you can see from today and from
the 2000 games that have come through
the program
um in the last seven years we love
variety
we're eager to support like all
developers especially if you're a new
developer this is your first game
maybe you're not from the united states
or you're from a different territory
like
please apply um you know we're really
eager to help you get your games uh on
the platform there's a huge
audience of players who want to play
your games you know i don't want to be
crashed but but
independent developers on on xbox have
earned more than
you know two billion dollars like way
over two billion dollars in the last
seven years from
shipping their games and that just feels
really good because it means that we
have a sustainable marketplace where
developers can have success and
keep making their games and so i guess
that would be my message there is a lot
of success on xbox whether it's
getting millions and millions of people
to play your game through game pass
just shipping your game and having lots
and lots of people play it and enjoy it
you know please come aboard
wow chris i want to thank you for taking
the time to spend and chat with us
but before we do say goodbye can you let
everyone at home know
how to apply to the program yeah
absolutely
devs just need to go to xbox.com id
and you can fill out an application
there i think maybe it takes like
five or six minutes to apply and you
know that's the easy part the hard part
is making the game but the part of
building a relationship with microsoft
and everything like that we try to make
that as easy as possible
awesome well again thank you so very
much for joining us today this has been
so
enlightening to kind of take a peek
behind the curtain at how all of this
works
it has been so lovely having you chris
if people want to find you online
is there a place that they can follow
you personally or should they just
follow id
xbox uh they can follow uh at id
underscore xbox or i'm at iocat on
twitter
awesome chris thank you so much for
popping by today and uh hopefully we'll
see you here on twitch gaming again soon
absolutely thanks a lot guys bye
oh that was so awesome and it seems
almost simple for developers to apply
i didn't know that it was almost that
easy that's pretty cool
yeah go to a website and it takes about
five or six minutes and
i've known about the id at xbox program
for years and how it helps indie devs
get their games out there and get their
games finished
um and what an awesome program it is but
yeah i also didn't know how easy it was
for devs to apply so for anyone watching
this
who has a game mulling around up here
even if it's just in concept phase
xbox.xbox.com id is what chris told us
and uh fill it out there and see if you
can help
if xbox can help bring your game to
reality and you know bring it to us
oh my gosh i mean i feel like what chris
was saying
sometimes starting is the hardest part
but to even put your foot in the door by
applying to the program i mean oh my
gosh
i know there's some developers in the
chat watching go ahead and get started
i'll see you guys in there
let's do it yeah yeah i and i absolutely
love
uh like i said i've been following this
program for a while when you go to a
convention like an e3 and you go to kind
of microsoft's
convention floor booth like their
section of it there's always an id at
xbox section
and whereas a lot of people go in and
kind of hunt for the big
aaa's i'm usually scanning the floor for
the id at xbox section because that's
where i'm gonna go
and find the games that like you said
brianna you know if you're in it for art
style
if you're looking for like the game that
brings out all the feels that you need
to have a tissue box handy for if you're
looking for those
fantastic uh scores and compositions a
lot of times that's where i'm like oh i
will find something
really unique that maybe i haven't
checked out here um
which is just it's just fantastic and
you know as we mentioned
cuphead was an id at xbox game there's
so many
so i i believe oxenfree
might have been originally as well um so
many great games and i
know people in chat are uh teasing and
hoping for
games that we will talk about a little
bit later in the show as well so don't
worry we've got lots of stuff coming
we do we have so much coming but up next
everyone streamer kate stark
will sit down with the team behind the
new game moon glow bay
which takes place along the peaceful
eastern canadian coastline
during the 1980s in moon glow bay you
play as an
old rookie angler struggling to keep
your business afloat
while coming to terms with the death of
your long life
partner lifelong partners sorry but
after exploring the world a little bit
you come to learn not everything
is what it seems let's take a look at
the trailer
[Music]
well guppy you did it your first catch
40 years and you still surprised me
i know this place seems strange a
fishing town afraid to fish
but that's why our new venture might
just stay afloat
because all those stories about the
mystical monsters of moonglow
are exactly that stories
this bay is full of amazing new
creatures
waiting to be discovered so we'll find
them
and share them with the world together
as long as this book is by your side
so am i
welcome home
[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us zach and lou
uh welcome to the show can you tell us a
little bit about moon glow bay
of course yeah uh so mugo is like uh
like was said
in east uh a fishing rpg slice of life
set in eastern coast of
1980s canada no fictional yeah and
and it's in a town that people are
afraid to fish because of mysterious
things yeah weird
creatures yeah well it starts out like a
kind of scenario where
the game is very regular and you're like
oh it's normal fish
it gets weirder and weirder and you're
like okay what's actually going on here
people have these myths and there's some
truth to these myths and so
it's a little spooky and you get your
fashion you get to cook and sell
and make friends around the town build
the town out so like while you're trying
to
explore explore the world figure out
what happened to your uh longhouse
partner
the town itself is going through their
own struggles with uh
their potential closing and inability to
to grow
and survive so it's kind of like a in
tandem
everyone helping each other each other
yeah
sounds amazing now without spoiling too
much what can you tell us about the town
and what went into creating life in
moonlope
oh it does the town is having its
centennial
so it's going to be 100 years old and
it's completely falling apart it has no
money the town hall is closing and you
kind of like
gotta help you moved into the town
three years prior with your partner
thing like okay we're gonna retire here
and we're going to just open up a little
fishing shack
but then uh they go on their adventure
your partner goes under adventure to
start up the shop
and they never come back so you so now
you're kind of like left alone you're
like
i don't know what to do and everyone
else is also closing down they're like i
need to like i want this to survive and
your daughter comes back and it's like
kind of like picks you up and says let's
do this let's figure this out
let's fix this down up yeah yeah and um
and
there was so much like i did so much
research on my on my site like doing
concept
art and stuff about eastern canada in
the 80s like going to
like little groups and checking like
people's memories and the photos that
they took of the of
the east coast of canada so and also in
the fashion because even though it was
70
80's the fashion hadn't caught up for
like 20 years
no it definitely had not
well i mean what inspired the story on
moonglo bay then
because it seems that you did a lot of
research into it so you must like and
very specifically eastern canada as well
so
what inspired that uh well i mean i like
uh i always like fishing games i think a
lot of us always
very much like playing the mini games i
mean fishing games yes rpgs and yeah
so it's just like it's one of those
things i was like well what if like this
has to be feasible it's a whole scope
game and i found
and with loads of other mini games yeah
it's like
legend of the river king like was almost
like 10 years ago almost 13 years ago
since it came out and i was like
nah this has to be like we need to kind
of like see if it's feasible here so
and like the the story is like zach and
i met uh living
in quebec yeah uh and like my family has
history with fishing
zach has as a kid i i helped run a
little fishing shop
selling fish by the lakeside and and it
was kind of like you know there's this
connection
like this is actually really chill we
wanted to make a game that was very
relaxing
and this is the perfect kind of thing
because fishing is pretty chill
and yeah we just felt like it was the
perfect
environment to start off and then we
just from there started researching east
coast because we want to go into the
ocean and get this vast space
and also it it was a little bit of
wonderlust of mine because
my my dream has always been like i'm
gonna list i'm gonna go live in nova
scotia it's like the most beautiful
place most calming place
so it kind of has that that part as well
yeah like that
uh yeah that's starry eyed feel like a
new new town
beautiful and that's why like one of the
things in the game is to kind of build
this town up and make it prettier over
time
so there is also a little bit of mystery
around the story and around the town
uh are you able to tell us a little bit
about that sure yeah like a little hint
which is basically like
there's a lore that exists in the world
itself it's not like the fish aren't
typical
and they start off typical but as you
get deeper you get into different
biomes so like regular water is what
you're seeing right now but then like it
spreads into like these sulfur zones
these like
heavy glacier zones and you're like how
does this doesn't exist in oceans
how does this happen and so it's kind of
like the mystery
that's also like part of the thing that
is making people so afraid like people
go fishing and they don't come back
and and they just it's completely
everything is kind of fueled by myths in
the town because nobody has the courage
to actually go fish and find out if the
myths are true or not so you kind of
like
everyone just gossip to each other yeah
yeah so you can go talk around you're
going to fill up a journal
to see what these myths that people have
accumulated are and then you can go and
like
see what truth there is to this and
something like there's always be like
okay go to this location
you're going gonna find just this weird
fish that's gonna like nibble at your
ankles you're like wait what
and so yeah so it's like stuff like that
uh for the player to find out
uh so more specifically on that how do
the game mechanics work what can players
expect
uh when playing moon globe for the first
time yeah
so it's a core loop of going out fishing
and then coming back and cooking
whatever you've caught
uh in your home and then you sell it at
your venues yeah it's a lesser like
less intense mechanic the selling itself
yeah the cooking is like a bunch of fun
mini games
like cooking mama style kind of stuff
yeah and the fishing is like you have
several different kinds of fishing you
can uh rod fishing is the one that goes
the most complex it has like different
levels of
difficulty based on the fish and
equipment and then there is trap fishing
there is ice ice fishing fishing and
line fishing which is like a little bit
more musical
so like you choose the style that you
wanna you wanna fish with and
tricks which capture this hundred plus
yeah and there's like certain fish that
can only be caught with certain tools so
you're gonna have to kind of
go around and figure out what these
combinations are
and also in your boat you can expand
with the money you've accumulated you
can expand the size of your boats the
tooling within it
uh to get a little bed and a kitchen in
the boat itself so he came to
fishing for days so you can go fishing
out at sea for days rather than always
having to come back to town
yeah i love the sound of that now i know
a question that a lot of our audience is
going to be
wondering and asking and i am myself can
you pet the dog
because i notice there's a dog can you
pet the dog
you can pet the dog the dog is going to
follow you follows you around your
little companion
his name is waffles waffles
oh i've been invited with this game
already this is my favorite game for
sure
um lou you were mentioning the art style
what inspired
and influenced the art style for this
game
so uh zach and i like ever since we met
we did a bunch of like
little mock-ups and stuff trying to
figure out like what game do we want to
make and it started from the principle
that zach
does voxel art and also like
i wanted to to bring something really
relaxing so one of the things that
it doesn't look like it because it's all
squared and it's like has a specific
palette and stuff but one thing that
inspires me a lot
on their direction is uh like ponyo from
from city jubilee yes yes yes
yeah so it's kind of like as well as
animal crossing
like and harvest the old harvest moons
from the gba
so all those things that are very
relaxing games that
kind of slice of life and all the colors
are much softer
yeah it's it's all intentionally like
catered so you don't feel intimidated by
anything even if like our myths are a
little bit spooky kind of thing so yeah
we kind of wanted the player to just
like
get home from work in this case like
finish work and then like maybe
open open the game and just relax and
distress from life i'm seeing a lot of
people in chat mention that exact
that exact thing so i think you're on
the right track uh what sort of
play time can people expect is it single
player is it multiplayer
what do we think it's single and um
it can be dropping drop out like it's
more more of a style of like a cyst
so if you're having difficulty of
catching a fish your friend can just
like
or your daughter or anyone can just grab
the controller and say i'm gonna help
you catch this face and you can grab
on to your player one and pull with them
to pull the fish in
so you go alongside the story and stuff
and then the place the play time
i'm we're estimating roughly around 10
to 12 hours uh depends if you want to be
a completionist and try to get
all the 100 plus fish in the game and
all the side quests and stuff or if you
just want to follow the or if you just
want to go through the story yeah
so just depending on how players want to
play i love that yeah so
the range can be pretty pretty pretty
big
yeah absolutely now what are you most
excited as the developers what are you
most excited for players to experience
when playing this for the first time for
me it's honest
i'm excited to see what people how
people react to the fish that they pull
up
because we get really weird with their
designs and
oh god i really love like for me the the
whole friendship
system like how you can become best
friends with people in town and they can
tell you like
their life stories or you can help them
with their little
their little struggles and stuff like
that that that is the kind of things
that i love in games so i'm looking
forward to
people seeing that as well that's
fantastic
now tell us really quickly about um
scripting an indie game
and how is it challenging with that
aspect of game design
it's it's chaotic um it's
one of those things that initially
you're going to have a like set idea
where you're like okay you have this and
it's going to be so big oh yeah you can
have some
idea that's massive the scope is always
gonna be huge and then you kind of as
you're building out you kind of build
the first section and then you're like
okay how long is this gonna be
and you play through and you're like um
all right yeah that uh and can we keep
pulling out this amount of like
story and work and yeah through the
entire game
like we've been making this game for
over over two three years yeah
and uh a lot of iteration has gone
through and we're just like okay yeah
yeah we have to
keep cutting and it's interesting
because we also like some
we're still developing the game and like
as we develop it we play it and
like the storyline actually doesn't fit
very well so maybe we're gonna have to
change it and it goes a lot like a lot
of work kind of goes down
but the big thing is that we've always
kept like the main beats of the game and
so long as you can tie between all of
those beats then the length between it
is not what matters is not what matters
so much in terms of like
the like how long that is if you can tie
them cleanly then i think the players
will always be happy with it because
they're going to feel satisfied in the
story's telling
right and you were mentioning through
storytelling in a little bit earlier
that there is
a good amount of lore in the game um and
i'm
understanding that the lore is
definitely playing a bigger role than i
may have thought
can you tell us a little bit about the
lore
uh the lore is i think it's it's hard
without spoiling
without spoiling too much but like one
of it is like the the reason why some of
the people
in town are afraid is because the
fishermen who die
at sea are their spirits are taken
within the waters within the ocean
and that's what manifests like these
weird fish
and stuff it's taking like from people's
thoughts
and um so yeah it's it's like their
weird thoughts and their weird
imagination kind of brings up
things in the sea yeah so and that's
that's just a tinge i want to see more
but i also don't want to
yeah no not spoiling is very very good
um we'll steer off of that just to get
away from spoilers for a little bit but
how did your team approach replayability
um yeah so that was a little a little
hard
on the story part it's mostly like
we're trying to make uh different
challenges in the fishing itself even
though it's like
it's a relaxing game but we still wanted
to give different levels to all the
to the types of fishing yeah and it's
one of the big things is that um
adding value to that replayability and
although all the way we've done it is
tying to that story because the law is
so interesting to to player base
every bit of thing that work you're
doing every added work you're doing
goes towards that story and uh you've
got a lot of collecting
so that's one of the reasons why we
added so many fish it's because we
wanted like
people to always have a surprise when
they they're playing the game like
there's always something new and like
different zones have different
new stuff for you so you don't have to
100 all the
all the fish in the game to complete the
game but you can you can keep going
after
that and learning more of the stories as
someone who'd likes to replay comfort
games
like this and i think i would classify
this as a bit of a comfort game
i'm very very happy to know that there
is that option
um before we say goodbye because this
has been lovely speaking to both of you
how can people follow you
uh for updates on moonglobe so we
have the mongol bay twitter account an
instagram account facebook page it's all
at [ __ ] bay
and we also the studio itself is at
bunny hook games on twitter
and also there is our publisher that is
also going to be giving a bunch of
updates which is at codesync like code
and sync yeah
okay that's yeah so that's where we can
find thank you so much
very much i know i'm excited to be
taking these updates
uh and i'm gonna be wish listing that as
soon as i get off of here
uh thank you so much for your time and
uh let's send it back to story mode bay
and trisha hershberger
see ya see ya bye
thank you and thank you zack and lou
what a fun look at moon glow bay
um i mean as soon as we got that little
nugget of lure
where people who die in the ocean people
who die at sea
their spirits and thoughts or what not
kind of come to be in the fish i was
like oh man this
this went from peaceful fishing sim
where i want to like romance different
people in town to something entirely
different
yeah no i completely agree i love how
kate
kind of called it a comfort game because
it almost is
a comfort game with you know um not the
death part maybe i don't know how
comforting that is
but it looks so adorable and again the
art style for me is what really drew me
in
it's almost like that pixelated type of
look you don't really
see that too commonly in games now and i
love that you know they brought that
back and yeah i'm putting it on my wish
list i need that
yeah i saw people in chat saying it's
kind of like minecrafty looking but with
upgraded graphics at least that's what
people were reminded of
and everyone was getting excited when
they saw there was crafting in it too so
we learned different types of fishing
cooking mini games uh sell everything in
a vending machine
meeting different people in town and
just for zach and lou like
to be indie devs who kind of created
this world i'm sure it's just so
exciting to
invite people into the world and see
what they do just like hands off we made
the playground
now the ball is in you go for it which
is really cool
right yeah i'm excited i'm excited for
them
all right folks we have to take a quick
break but don't go anywhere we have more
exclusive trailers coming up i see
everyone in chat that's like trailers
trailers trailers trailers we'll get
there
we have more exclusive trailers coming
up and coming up interviews with the
devs from soup pot
nobody saves the world among us and more
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the id at xbox
showcase
right here on twitch gaming my name is
trisha hershberger and i am joined by
the fantastic story mode bae today
to tell you about all things going on on
the indie scene
from the xbox yes oh my gosh
like we were saying earlier on in the
show we have such an incredible
lineup for all of you uh coming up soon
blind gamer steve will sit down with the
team behind soup pot
and later on we'll be talking to
victoria from among us
i know everyone in the chat is waiting
for that interview
about the new map that will be dropping
in the game on march
31st but first we have more
exciting game trailer reveals for you
from drifting across
gorgeous rally racing landscapes to
surviving the cold and desolate
wilderness our next announcements are
coming to the xbox platform
soon let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you don't see is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
always be true
[Music]
meet the creepy ai driven mr peterson
this character has one mission keeping
you from discovering his
secrets hello
and welcome to hello neighbor 2. in this
game you'll be playing as a local
journalist
named quentin who is suspicious of his
creepy neighbor
mr peterson for those new to the hello
neighbor franchise
this is raven brooks the sort of town
where everyone keeps to themselves and
goes about their lives
normally you would too except a bunch of
people have gone missing
and there's just something strange about
your neighbor mr peterson
everyone is afraid of him there have
been rumors of children going to his
house
and never being heard from again some
people say
he likes to lock people up in his
basement
but no one has any proof so people just
try to avoid mr peterson his odd house
and ignore the strange sounds coming
from his basement that night
you have a feeling that mr peterson is
behind all of the neighborhood
disappearances
but no one believes in your ideas and
theories and while you normally wouldn't
break into someone's house
you're the only one who believes
something is wrong and has the guts to
uncover the truth
when you break into mr peterson's house
you'll be going against an ai that is
constantly evolving
our goal for hello neighbor 2 is to
provide unique player experiences
this is an experience that is driven by
the community
mr peterson's behavior is a combination
of a neural network
and algorithms that allow him to
constantly learn from his experiences
with everyone who plays our game it
begins with the collection of player
activity
mr peterson takes note of player
behavior whether or not most players are
likely to hide in a closet
use a certain escape route or certain
objects as time progresses then he
learns mr peterson's behavior may change
and surprise you how mr peterson plays
in one encounter with you
might be different from the next all due
to his encounters with the games
community
as a whole in this way the community's
experience with mr peterson
changes over time allowing for an ai
that is developed through community
actions
replayability and great stories of
neighborhood shenanigans
but these new experiences go beyond mr
peterson
in hello neighbor 2 players can interact
with all characters in raven brooks
and these characters share the same ai
core
but behave differently and have their
own stories for you to discover
so while you might think you're just
playing the game you're really
contributing to the development and
improvement
of mr peterson's ai
we hope this presentation of our ai and
development gives you an idea of what to
expect in hello neighbor 2.
if you'd like to try an early access
version of hello neighbor 2 you can
check out some of our alphas on the
microsoft store
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the neighborhood
i played the first one and i was kind of
petrified
like he was finding me from every little
corner i remember trying to hide in the
rooms
and he was right there waiting for me so
the fact that they're making a second
one
and he's even smarter than the first
game i'm nervous
i'm very nervous well that was one of
the coolest things about the first hello
neighbor is that you know he would adapt
to your play style and the more that you
would do runs the smarter he would get
but now not having it only be your runs
but the entire community's runs
that mr peterson's learning from is
frankly quite terrifying to me although
i'm super interested that they said that
the other neighbors will all have
stories and will be able to interact
with the other
neighbors as well that's super cool i
love that in hello neighbor too we get a
little bit
of a motivation as to why we're invading
this man's house whereas i feel like in
the first hallow neighbor you're just
like those
meddling kids yes that are
bugging don't throw your ball over in my
yard again and yeah
exactly exactly now i was going to say
i was very happy to see that uh team 17
is coming out with another game
they're the same developers that made
overcooked and even
the style of the game it looks very 80s
and retro and almost futuristic in a way
which is super exciting to see
uh the first trailer that we saw with
the car
driving again a beautiful art style i
mean wow
these trailers are blowing me away it is
a great time to be a gamer
yeah that first trailer we saw uh was
for a game called art of rally
which got high praise from the folks at
top gear and being
a little a little bit of a uh a car
enthusiast if you will
an auto enthusiast i was like man okay
loving it
that's that's some high praise again uh
for art of rally
craftopia looked cool and i saw a lot of
rust fans in chat yeah we were showing
rust console edition
so for our console gamer friends you
will be able to get
into the world of rust if uh if that's
your jam i've dabbled a little bit
in rust myself although i dabbled on a
friendly server so i know it could be a
lot more intense
if i was in a more survival based server
where everybody's out to get everybody
else uh but yeah
console friends welcome here we go rust
um but all right so that was just some
more trailers for everybody to check out
i know chat is all about those trailers
up next on the show we have uh streamer
blind gamer steve
we'll chat with the dev team behind the
new cooking inspired game
soup pot in soupat you'll be able to
make food with a wide range of locally
sourced or
supermarket ingredients in traditional
kit
and traditional kitchens uh discover and
learn more than 100 recipes
while streaming your cooking on cookbook
the in-game social media map okay so
we've got like a cooking game and a
streaming game
let's just take a look at the trailer
let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
super super super super super super
super
[Music]
oh i am really really excited hello i'm
steve aka blind gamer steve
and uh to introduce our guest stars is
what i'm here to do it really makes me
happy to introduce to you gwen
and trina from chicken club studios
hello gwen and trina how are you
tell us all about it what is it tell us
more we
need to know more details so it's really
weird so like
our game it's very chaotic it's like
uh to summarize in one sentence it would
probably be
a chaotic cooking game where you don't
need a recipe there's no fail states in
this game you just
do what you do what you do in the
kitchen you improvise
so the player would be uh quote unquote
streaming
their process in the kitchen and um
uh in asian culture we don't really have
fixed measurements for cooking we just
like we eyeball everything and then
we adjust them according to taste we
just listen to the voices of our
ancestors in the background
and we want to replicate this way of
cooking because we think
it would be fun to play especially um
uh we wanna we wanted to do uh
the iconic cooking methods like using
our fingers to
measure how much water to put uh when
you're cooking rice
yeah that is so cool um and you
mentioned
you mentioned we talked before um like
by the way thank you for for tuning in
this is i know it's you're in the
philippines and it's way past midnight
where you are so thank you so much but
i wanted to ask because you said that it
was uh that the soup
is very filipino and asian inspired can
you tell us a little bit more about how
that inspiration is
part of the game uh
so actually like trina and i
both love to cook that's one one of the
things
and then the pandemic happened
and trina and i were just like oh you
know like we're not doing anything like
we're just at home
we don't get to eat out and then
uh we decided to make this so last year
we released the demo which was called
edition and then we dipped in the
streaming part of it
uh and people really liked it so one of
the things that
we wanted is like gia i
started we asked gia to do sound design
where
she talks about uh she says the
ingredients names
and that carried over into our actual
game
like when we saw how much people enjoy
the demo
and they really like it like we feel
like we're filling in a gap
where it's not too serious gaming like
it's not instructional
you know like we want to recreate as
much as you know how you would be in the
kitchen
which is you measure by feeling you fix
things as you go
things can get messed up and you know
like we just want to bring in that fun
into the game and make it a game like
the fact that when you look at games in
general cooking game is
always like a mini game just like a side
thought
and we both love cooking like we both
love food also so we wanted
to put cooking itself as the focus of
our game
that is so awesome now we did see
actually a little bit in that trailer
that there's a
social network in this game called
cookbook can you tell us a little bit
about that and how that ties in
to the progression system in the game
so cookbook itself uh
we wanted a way to wrap the game
and then it's essentially like fake
facebook
where you could look in and then you
have like tasty like videos
uh and you learn there's also the
currency news
yeah there's also current news and then
essentially like you learn by watching
videos
of the game so you also learn techniques
like through a combo fighting system
that we want
but then there's also an accessibility
option where
we've made it so that you could actually
remap the controls so that
you you make you
you could you know adjust the game to
your play style
and which is something yeah i was going
to ask about that actually
because because of course i'm an
accessibility advocate and consultant so
accessibility is very much a big part of
of my life and and what i do
so what are the other accessibility uh
features that you're gonna actually have
in in supot so one of the things
that like we really care for is that
like dyslexia like one of our team
members
has dyslexia so that's very important to
us
uh we've that was a very long discussion
you know whether we
put in like qte or whether
uh we and to balance that so that people
feel like they're progressing in the
game
another thing is that trina
is designing you know colorblind uh
filters so
that we make sure that the game is also
playable to people
who may not see the colors
we've added in like their actions like
the lines so that
you have like sort of an indicator of
what's happening in the kitchen
and then it was semi-incidental that
you know our sound design in
gia like they just really
made the game so well like the sound
design is so well that
all the audio feedback uh you know
really helps you play the game like you
could
you could play it also like by listening
uh
that is so that is so cool i can't wait
to be able to to try that out
now trina i wanted to ask you because
apparently i understand you're you're
the queen of meme over there at chicken
club
so i i heard that you said that there's
some really creative
and meme driven achievements in this
game can you tell us a little bit about
what we're gonna look forward to and you
mentioned to me earlier
there's a five-second rule achievement
can you tell us a little bit about that
so our achievements aren't skill based
they're basically
um based on how much fun you have in the
kitchen
so we have this uh thing where
if you drop an english an ingredient on
the floor
and you decide to pick it back up up and
put it on the pot
uh the game will record that and mark
that as an achievement for the five
second rule
because you you're still using the
ingredients that you that fell on the
floor
and there's also this oh no i'm spoiling
a lot of things but
anyway uh there's there's also this
feature
um where you have a fake neighbor in the
background singing karaoke
and if you get too annoyed you can just
throw food at them
so oh my gosh
yeah that is so that is so amazing i
love that
um so by the way we should you should
probably mention
that they're like you got to make sure
that you have to turn the stove off
correct
you don't want to like that's going to
be an issue
uh you need to turn your stove off if
you're not using it because it's gonna
uh go in it's gonna gonna implement a
feature where
if you don't turn off the stove your
whole kitchen's gonna burn
yeah that's awesome um now you had also
actually
mentioned before that essentially
there's going to be
um the ability to have like kind of
different types of food from like
locally grown farmers and holiday food
can you tell us a little bit about that
and so one of the things is that we have
a marketplace
uh in cookbook the social media and then
what we wanted to do
is essentially uh if you wanted to make
like gourmet food and which like almost
all restaurants
what they do is that they source locally
and this is something that's very subtle
it's not really gonna affect like your
experience of the game
but we wanted to ensure that the design
of it
also reflects that you know
small like local farmers and homegrown
organic ingredients are just
better and like more fresh compared to
like um supermarket ones just because of
you know like fast food and like
waste and all of those things so you
don't necessarily feel that in the game
because you could buy whatever you want
and you know the no fail state and the
the you know quirky insults that both
trina and i grew up with
like that is how the game is so
i feel like it doesn't push the things
that we want but we've designed
the game in a way that it reflects that
i love that
now is this going to be a like a solo
single player experience or is there
going to be multiplayer in this at all
oh it's a solo experience yeah oh that's
awesome so you can kind of go at your
own pace i love that
so i bet there's a lot of people kind of
in the chat that are going to be
wondering like
where like when can we be able to get
our hands on soup
on xbox so currently we
we are aiming for august 31st uh
2021 and yeah
like that month is like pretty important
for us
when the game gets launched you also
could actually play
in a japanese and korean kitchen
because of like how close those culture
us to
what we're exposed to so there are a
couple of recipes and then you could
choose to cook
in a japanese or korean kitchen also
that is
so really cool i love that so much
uh all right so thank you so much gwen
and trina for for joining us uh where
can we be able to find more information
about
uh chicken club you and and uh and soup
yeah down oh
yeah all right that's awesome
we also have a twitter club yeah
a discord yeah yeah oh there's a discard
too just look them up
on twitter look them up online sue pot
will be coming uh very soon uh to xbox
thanks once again and i'm gonna send it
back to storybo
mode bay and trisha thank you so much
thank you
thank you steve thank you thank you
uh okay brianna are you a good cook
in real life um i've gotten better
yes when i first started cooking no not
really but it's almost like
trial and error i love what they were
saying earlier about how you know
in their culture there's no sense of
really
following recipes it's just you let the
ancestors guide you and
they'll tell you how much you need to
add that's the kind of cook i am
you know what i am i the self-professed
not a good chef
personally um and i'm watching this
thinking oh maybe this will make me a
better chef much like
dance dance revolution made nobody a
better dancer so no probably not
uh but at least it might make me have
some love
you know for for cooking i like the
wacky stuff that they talked about where
like
you can throw food at your karaoke
neighborhood that sounds hilarious
or that when you select food or i guess
pick it up the food yells out its name
yeah that's what i'm in for i'm in for
the wacky stuff
or even they were saying the five second
achievement if you drop some
food and as long as you pick it up blow
the dust off and put it back on the
stove within five minutes
you'll be good it's fine i'm excited to
play
five second rule for real yes
for real well everyone at home watching
coming up we will
chat with victoria from among us about
the new airship map coming over to the
game
and later streamer dana taj will have a
conversation with the devs behind
nobody saves the world i oh
i am very excited but first let's take a
quick break
be right back
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello everybody and welcome back
to
the id at xbox showcase right here on
twitch gaming
my name is trisha hershberger and i am
here today with brianna aka
story mode bay and we're kind of like
your tour guides
through this event today leading you to
all the different sections of things
that you
will want to see but we do have a lot of
great stuff coming up
we absolutely do next up everyone will
be hearing from the creative team behind
nobody saves the world
and they will be interviewed from none
other than denotage
but before we get to that interview we
have more gameplay trailers to reveal
from the battle of normandy to the
skrama medieval combat this
next batch of games promises something
for everyone
let's take a look
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you did absolutely everything
[Music]
[Music]
it's time for my butt to sit on your
throne
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kill them
[Music]
we make our stand here and now
how sweet
this is
8015
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
if you need to just zen out um i saw
blank arcadian in chat
when we were watching the trailer for uh
king of iron said assassin's creed of
persia
and i just thought that was hilarious
but you're mentioning things that i love
uh blank arcadian uh so king of iron
might be right up there as well
rihanna did you have any of those
trailers that jumped out at you that you
were like yes i got to play that
yeah that first one uh demon turf i
think it was called
definitely caught my eye it's kind of
like a 3d platformer but what i liked
about is they kind of experimented
with that 2d style a little bit as well
so yeah i
i'm excited about this also what i'm
equally as
excited about is our very next interview
coming up
up now streamer daniel taj is going to
connect with the devs behind
nobody saves the world from the
developers of guacamelee
oh i love that name comes nobody saves
the world which is a twist on an action
rpg in which you play many different
character forms each with their own
unique gameplay mechanics you get to
explore
a bass overworld uh clearing generated
dungeons in an effort to beat back the
calamity
and save the world let's check out the
[Music]
trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo wow uh that trailer was awesome i've
seen that like three times now it's
fantastic my name is daniel taj
hello everybody i'm joined by the
lovely lovely human beings named grand
smith and ian campbell from
drinkbox games the lovely people that
brought you guacamelee and guacamelee 2
now bring you nobody saves the world hi
guys
hey how are you doing i'm doing
fantastic that
like i'm not joking that trailer gets me
amped
every single time i've seen it like four
times now and it's
it's fantastic the uh the music's a bop
the game looks fantastic let's
i mean let's talk about it there's so
many things to get into we don't have a
ton of time let's
dive right into it what what what do you
guys want to start with we got
all kinds of things uh well let's
we can explain a little bit about uh the
gameplay how it works and what we're
going for with the game
uh so yeah please i guess uh yeah nobody
saves the world
uh well just to start off the that that
uh naked gray baby that you saw that
picked up the wand at the start of the
trailer there that's nobody
uh that's what you start the game as uh
and so like right at the start of the
game you find this magic wand
uh which allows you to change uh your
form into different types of forms
uh so so the game is basically like a
top-down rpg
action rpg uh but you're as you're
playing you're progressing through this
form tree and you're unlocking new forms
and
playing as different forms uh and
experiencing like completely different
types of
start of the game the very gameplay form
you'll unlock is uh you gain the ability
to turn into a rat
and you actually use the use that
ability to escape imprisonment you get
you get imprisoned at the start of the
game um and then uh
so once you escape from your prison you
notice that the rat has this long list
of quests that the rat can do
using the rats abilities and when you
start when you start working on those
quests and completing those quests
your rat starts to rank up and gain new
abilities and you also unlock
additional forms that you can switch to
which have their own list of quests
uh so slowly throughout the game as
you're playing you're unlocking new
character classes which we call forms
and exploring those different gameplay
mechanics with the different forms
unlocking new abilities unlocking more
forms you can see a little bit of of the
the form tree in the video right now you
can see that the player just turned into
the rat
um yeah so in a quick nutshell that's
kind of what the game is about
so if i so the forums it sounds like
it's
good for you're showing exploratory
stuff and
being able to kind of puzzle solve a
little bit um
i assume there's a lot that goes on with
how your gameplay is going to be with
combat and such
uh yeah absolutely like every form
has their own play styles and their own
moves like some are about
like applying status effects to enemies
and taking advantage of that some are
like real heavy hitters but
uh you know they need like long windups
and they need an element of like timing
to them
uh yeah some can fly some can swim
there's like lots of combat and
traversal mechanics
and as you get further into the game you
can mix and match the abilities
between the forms so you know then you
have like
a rat that can shoot arrows like a
ranger or
a horse that's you know like biting
things and poisoning like a rat whatever
uh so
the the possibilities are nearly endless
you could say
yeah that we were uh we talked about a
little bit before and i think that's the
thing that intrigued me most it sounds
like
there's sort of a kind of lego
plug-and-play
i get to pick different forms and kind
of play with them is there like
like how complicated can we get it gets
pretty complicated um
like to start with when you unlock a new
form the forms quests are all kind of
like training you how to use that forms
because we want to ease the player into
the new mechanics that are presented
with each form
uh so so it'll be like getting you to
use your basic abilities um
but then once you've once you've kind of
started to get the hang of a form we
start giving new quests that
you can't do with the base abilities of
the form you actually have to uh
mix and match pull it in abilities from
other other classes uh so
like for example if you're playing as
the rat the rat doesn't have any ranged
abilities but the rat might get a quest
to you know use ranged abilities to kill
enemies so then you so you have some
flexibility on how you wanna
how you wanna do that that's a pretty
easy quest to do uh because there's lots
of options for something like that but
they do start to get more specific and
they um some of them are more difficult
to figure out like how exactly how am i
going to do this and different
customizations
uh it gives the player some room for
creativity
in trying to complete the quests that
they're presented with
yeah that's that's awesome i mean i that
was probably the thing i was most
excited for
when sort of hearing about this was it
it looks very much
like well it looks like my gym i'm gonna
be honest and it looks like it's a lot
of chats jam as well
uh so i think we're all pretty excited
about that but that that sort of freedom
to
play within your rules as the developers
but also be able to kind of
do things on our own and get get pretty
creative and
and play with like the tools that you
brought up i think that's
that's pretty awesome um not to mention
i mean
just simply like uh a geopart says the
art style of this game looks
amazing and i couldn't agree more uh
there's just so much stylistic uh virtue
to it
and it seems like it's you're taking a
lot of inspiration from your past works
like like guacamelee can we can we talk
about like
what are sort of the things that maybe
you learned in the past that you brought
to something like nobody saves the world
uh actually i mean talking with the
artists uh through the development
process of course like
one of the goals is to try and break a
bit free
from what we had done previously i guess
in terms of say like
cyber and guacamelee have a very like
angular vectorized art style but this is
more like hand-drawn and
like lots of lines and strokes and stuff
uh and we we also wanted it to be
kind of charming but like
off-putting like i i know like
maybe like red and stimpy or like a
garbage pail kids
were referenced in the art team where
like
it's like appealing but also
uncomfortable yeah
yeah yeah it looks like there's a little
bit of grunge going on and then
like like you said that tangerine art
style is pretty
unique it in because nobody does it the
same right not really at least
that's awesome yeah absolutely um so
i've seen some like some mentions and
something that i sort of came up with or
came up just kind of watching it for the
first time was
um a lot of thoughts of like it being a
roguelite but i wanted to drive home
that
it isn't a roguelite it's very much an
action rpg but
you guys have something very special
which is i mean do you always want to
talk about your dungeons a little bit
uh yeah absolutely so yeah the structure
of the game uh
it's kind of like you're exploring a
large overworld not
not unlike uh one of the older 2d zelda
games uh
but it's scattered throughout this over
world there's dungeons
everywhere we have about 25 dungeons
right now in the game uh
and all of the dungeons are procedurally
generated so
um and they all have completely
different themes as well so
uh so like we have some standard things
like you know a prison or a mine but we
have a lot of really
odd non-standard things like you'll be
exploring a ufo
or a gingerbread house or you'll be
going inside of a dead dragon
uh like just trying to do some weird
bizarre things um and each of the
dungeons while they're
procedurally generated they're uh they
all have like different rules in their
generations so
each dungeon does like have a unique
feeling when you go inside of it
um but if you do die inside of a dungeon
because you know
there's the dungeons are going to get uh
increasingly difficult if you
do die you're kicked back up front and
it gives you a chance to try and create
a new build
uh uh to go back in again and and try to
be more successful with another attempt
and another thing we do as the game
progresses is we start to add more
more mechanics to the game so uh you
can't
just like find a a form or a combo
of abilities that is like ultra powerful
and just stick with that for the whole
game because the dungeons will present
different challenges uh so you'll have
to kind of mix and match
um not only because you want to try and
push down the the form tree by
doing quests as different forms to
unlock more classes but
because some of the dungeons you just
won't be able to do with certain forms
because
this those forms won't be well suited
with their abilities to do that dungeon
so yeah and i was gonna pick i was gonna
try to find the most broken thing i
could possibly find just played
the whole time now we still we still do
some
uh from time to time we do like uh give
the players some places where they can
just put together their best
most powerful form just because they
want we want you to be able to feel that
experience but there are some builds
that feel pretty broken so we can't just
let you
do that dang it
i mean speaking of very powerful things
uh
you showed a couple it looked like
bosses straight up
from from the trailer and i'm
that's like where my bread and butter
comes from is where i
what i'm always interested it's like oh
the the dungeoning is like super fun and
super awesome
where's the boss and what sort of things
can you tell us about maybe some of
these these high level uh
enemies uh okay i
i share your love of bosses um they're
they're in the game they're not as much
of a focus they do exist
um the i think the like enemies and the
hazards
in the dungeons are almost more like
the bosses if that makes sense because
like yep yes it does
okay because like like ryan was saying
some
dungeons like they all have their
different themes and some of them are
pushing like really hard in certain
directions like
i just came in this dungeon and there's
like poison everywhere and there's
projectiles flying at me everywhere like
and you're like okay well what forms and
what abilities can i use to like
overcome this
and and that's kind of the focus of the
dungeon
um so then like a final encounter within
that dungeon could just like lean
more heavily on that uh elements sure
no that's cool i mean because we yeah i
mean there are a lot of
there are a lot of games that sort of
focus on yeah well
this is cool you're building up you're
trying not to die essentially but you
just got to get to the boss this sounds
like it's very much going to be
a challenge all the way through and i i
mean am i am i wrong in saying that
you're going to basically
i mean obviously you're going to be
having fun the whole time but are you
going to be
restarting pretty often if if you're not
necessarily like just a
savant at what these kinds of games
bring to you
i i don't think so we're not we're not
trying to go for like ultra hard
difficulty and we don't want
players to be like dying too frequently
and uh although there are some
places that are pretty difficult like
there are uh there are a few key
dungeons that you'll have to do
throughout the course of the game that
are
more difficult and those are the ones
that i was mentioning where we we kind
of like
allow the player more flexibility and
what their build is going to be going
into those dungeons because we want them
to feel
like like they're creating like really
powerful builds
um but but no in most of the dungeons
you could probably clear them
in like a small number of attempts and
like i said there's a lot of dungeons
though
we really want the player to be like
moving through the world and exploring
this vast overworld
meeting its inhabitants and also jumping
into all the dungeons that they're
finding and not just be stuck on a
dungeon and looping on a dungeon for too
too long
yeah cool that's awesome yeah that
sounds like yeah
you don't want you don't want something
to be too frustrating it's it's pretty
cool
i like uh i just like the visuals of
looking at the the tree and how it kind
of flows together
uh seems really easy to read which is a
relief
for a lot of things that have been you
know just kind of everywhere um
there's there's it seems like you really
paid attention to how everything looks
which is cool
um you mentioned also that there's
a lot of high-level story um is there
something that
we should look forward to sort of
getting into as far as like getting
fully immersed in
what sort of what sort of store are we
gonna be looking at
uh it's there's a lot of
variety i would say i guess that's like
a blanket statement about the whole game
is this trying to be like
charming and varied as much as possible
but like
i would personally say to look forward
to some of the characters you will meet
like my favorite is marty jo the hammer
curse who is just like
a person cursed to be a walking talking
hammer uh
he's got a really good storyline going
on uh but yeah there's all kinds of
like many strange people in many strange
situations that you're going to meet and
actually
it kind of ties into the quests that
like have been described a bit already
but the ones we talked about are kind of
like
combat quests but the story allows for a
whole lot of other quests
like one of them is to get sat on or one
of them is to like fall in love
and like so you're just you know you'll
always be finding these things as you're
going through the world it's
it's an exciting part of the story to me
that's awesome no that's that's that's
cool it sounds like there's a there's a
lot to look forward to i mean
just characters in general are fun to
sort of get attached to
um i'm hoping you don't make it sad with
any of these characters
i i'm not going to ask you to react to
that or anything but
i mean you know there was a whole thing
going on twitter it's like don't crash
just a video game but look at this game
and i feel like these types of games
where you introduce really cool
characters have a lot of opportunity
to make that happen so so i'm both
excited
and and hopefully i do not get too sad
with these things but uh it looks
really really awesome is there anything
that
that we may have missed that you would
like to show off today about
nobody saves the world i think we
covered most of it
um yeah awesome no that's fantastic
i'm looking forward to it um before we
before we fully wrap up
where can we where can we find nobody
saves the world where can we see
online and what sort of things should we
be following right now
uh you can definitely follow us on
twitter drinkboxstudios uh
we're also on facebook instagram and uh
we just
just today even maybe just like right
now we're opening up a public discord
for the studio so
you can if you want to know more about
the game see more cool stuff from the
game please
follow us on uh on discord i think it's
like discord
gg slash drinkbox um yeah those are the
those are the places to follow us
oh fantastic awesome thank you all so
much uh
thanks to graham and ian for joining me
thank you to everybody for watching this
please keep this on your list because i
i would love to see as many people
play this as possible so that i have
things to talk about with you all
um we're going to throw it right back to
uh story mode bay
and trisha thank you both for joining me
and thank you all so much for watching
see you guys thanks dan thanks
thank you so much to daniel taj and
drinkbox studios for that interview
oh my gosh nobody saves the world i
really like the fact that there's so
many generated
dungeons so the gameplay almost doesn't
feel repetitive
trisha how do you feel about it um i
thought it looked awesome i mean i saw i
was watching chat the whole time
during that interview and i saw simo
maso in chat says perfect mix of rpg
and roguelike which i thought yes that's
a good way to describe it because i mean
there were a lot of people saying oh
roguelike and
uh we heard we heard ian and graham say
well
kind of but also not really um but yeah
i mean there's
there's a lot to love here from the uh
from kind of the quirky characters and
interesting side missions that they
talked about that i do think it's gonna
have a lot of replayability i do think
this is a world that
i know for myself i'm probably going to
spend a lot of time in
i think that nobody saves the world
looks looks definitely
definitely interesting do you think it's
something you'll probably stream
yeah i mean i definitely want to check
it out and i love what you said too
about the replayability because i feel
like there's so many games where you
play
and it's almost like it's one and done
but no i want to get my money's worth i
want to play this
a couple of times over and feel so
excited about
each playthrough that i do so yeah i'm
definitely checking this out
chat at home what are you guys thinking
is there a game that you're super
excited about
that you've seen from the trailers
already or a game that you're looking
forward to
i mean looking at the chat i i i have a
good uh
feeling about what they're looking
forward to i'm seeing a lot of hype for
stalker
i'm seeing a hot a lot of hype for among
us i
i know what yeah i was feeling like oh
yeah um but i mean we've got
so much to get into today so let's go
ahead and keep this party rolling
um we've had so many great game
announcements already today but
next up we have a number of titles never
before revealed dun dun duh that's right
new game trailers let's take a look at
those now
yes
[Music]
this is our world or canon
it is a world gifted with magnificent
and generous
nature albeit sometimes harsh besides
ourselves the marios
our canon is home to the peska the zephs
the arctins and the uss
[Music]
oh we must not forget the mygmes the
mygmes bring our people together
and carry around crates containing an
essential ingredient for our society
this ingredient is called a harmon the
harmony between our people
depends on it
and last but not least let me tell you
about us
we are the demigods our mission is to
fight
and defeat the noises the mysterious
monsters that threaten our beautiful
harmony
the demigods will not allow anyone to
disrupt or canon's harmony
[Music]
ascend
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
oh man so much last oasis hype
in chat i loved it there's a lot there
was a lot to love there last oasis looks
great
lost lost eidolon's is maybe how you
pronounce i think so yes
um yeah loot river looked awesome
and i saw chat also very excited for
some of those things lawnmowing
simulator made me giggle if you want a
really really intense
very accurate lawn mowing simulator then
that could be you
um but last oasis is out right now on
xbox one
yeah yeah that is incredible and again
like you said there's so many fans at
home
watching you guys go play go download it
looks
incredible now i do have a couple of
questions about
la mowing simulator because um is there
a story mode
are you just kind of mowing the lawn
casually
i'm interested i i have a couple of
questions about it
but that last trailer for loot river oh
yeah i'm excited for it
it's almost like you're moving in a
puzzle type of motion
it's like an adventurous tetris if you
will oh i want to play it
oh yeah and the second that i see super
hot presents before any trailer i'm like
yes please let's get that um it looks
like it'll be challenging mixing the uh
puzzle play with the combat and the art
style looks cool the second i saw the
playing doctor helmet and like
wiping the blood off the front of it i
was like oh this is gonna be rad i'm
into
it and lost eidolons was like everything
i love about the medieval character
creator with what looked to be
turn-based tactical combat
i don't know if we can specifically tell
that from the trailer but that's at
least what it seemed to me
which when you combine those two things
that is something i am definitely
uh up for as well it looked really cool
absolutely now which one was the one
with the the guy and he was flying
in the air was that lost or am i
thinking about a different one
i'm trying to remember all these titles
they were so good
but that one looked exciting too maybe
last oasis last oasis was the one with
like the cool airships that everybody's
uh pedaling and it kind of takes place
in a
desert desk atmosphere so it might it
might be that that you were thinking of
but yeah
really really fun trailers i'm glad to
see everyone in chat getting hyped for
some games um
next up on the showcase today our next
guest is one of the creative minds and
developers
behind this small little indie title
that some of you
might know um called among us and on
march 31st a new map
the airship speaking of airships is
dropping into the game
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
trailer for the new map now
[Music]
welcome recruit get yourself acquainted
with the layout of the top at airship
enough slacking go do your tasks
you may need to take a ladder to get to
certain areas or maybe just take a nice
shortcut
quit grouping up choose a room to start
in after a meeting
someone keeps trying to sabotage us stop
their plan
keep your eyes peeled we definitely have
an impostor here
[Music]
hello victoria how are you today
i am great thank you for having me of
course thank you so much for being here
um the chat is so hype like they
are moving so incredibly fast i think
everyone is beyond it yes i think
everyone is
beyond excited not only for among us but
this new map
coming out um what can you tell us about
the airship
yeah so the airship is actually dropping
on
in like five days oh my goodness five
days so so it's very soon
uh yeah it's going to be our biggest map
ever it's going to come with an account
system
we have some free hats coming with it as
well as some cosmetics that you can buy
uh there will be all new tasks uh
there's gonna be ladders and moving
platforms it's gonna
it's gonna be um hopefully a lot of fun
for everyone to play with and
we are really excited for it to finally
be out
uh can you tell us for those of us they
really like to play
imposter or get chosen as imposter uh
can you tell us what the venting system
is like is this gonna have a fully
connected
vent system for that pro level play oh
you know it
oh i'm so excited i'm so excited to see
how everyone
uh gets around to murdering each other
oh i cannot wait to in in the best ways
murder my friends um but with that being
said
i thought it was really interesting from
the trailer that after meetings you're
able to select what room you spawn back
in
yeah so you know it it's going to be a
lot of fun it'll like definitely change
up the strategy
um and if you know you spawn in the same
room as the imposter and it's just you
two
good luck i mean whoops
uh do you have any pro strats for people
encountering a map that has
dual level play um yeah
um just run as fast as you can just
just trust no one run as fast as you can
you know all that kind of fun stuff um
yeah it's
it's going to be a lot and we hope like
in the future to
make bigger lobbies so you can have more
players but that's going to be coming in
the future
so um that's exciting
now i did recently learned that the
airship is going to be the biggest
map available does this mean that there
will be new tasks available
as well or new death animations maybe
yeah so there's going to be all new
tasks available and
there will be one near death animation
if you buy the additional cosmetic pack
that comes with it
um as you can see it's based on henry
stickman which is
another game that we made in the past so
there it is
it's right hand man's kill animation so
we're hoping people have a lot of fun
with it
oh man i'm so are you allowed to tease
what the new hats are
you saw i mean you saw lots of it in the
um
in the trailer but we will have some new
free hats such as
a unicorn hat like a little heart some
angry eyebrows
zipper uh a chocolate ice cream hat that
is definitely not poop
it's definitely chocolate ice cream and
nothing else
definitely doesn't look like anything
else
thank you for specifying but with that
being said
do you have any personal favorites about
this new map
honestly okay so i know it doesn't i
don't know why
i'm so excited about ladders but i am
it's just it's just like something it's
just so simple and there's really
nothing
that special about it but i just love
the like simplicity of ladders just
everywhere
i think that's cool i'm excited
complexity for the players so i wonder
you know you said this is going to
switch up people's strategies
how much are you watching gameplay are
you watching streamers to say all right
here's the main strategies that people
are running with right now that would
consider themselves
you know pro level at among us because
there are people out there who are very
good at this game
how much of their game play do you watch
when thinking like oh man we need to
switch it up
oh it really depends right so we do try
to keep up and
there's there's a lot thankfully we're
very grateful to have a lot of people
who play among us so that's really cool
but we do you know try to keep up and
see who's playing and kind of their
strategies and see
the kinds of cool things they come up
with uh but within ourselves actually
like we
with our game design and with our own
like qa and our own play testing
uh it's really a mix of like our own um
sensibilities
and you know just years of making games
and also just seeing how
the community runs with it yeah i mean i
feel like things like
you know visual tasks being able to be
on and off uh having the task bar
fill immediately stuff like that that
it's kind of like through playing it
you're like
oh this could be tweaked oh this could
be tweaked and not just necessarily like
tweak to make the game better just to
give people options of what you want the
difficulty to be and
i'm sure brianna and victoria can both
relate to this but it's like
you know if i'm playing among us with my
family members that don't game very
often
my settings are going to be very
different than if i'm playing with a
bunch of streamer friends that are
you know 24 7 among us players yes
definitely yeah i think the cool thing
right is just to see all the different
kinds of people that come together to
play among us
right it's not uh we've had classrooms
of
people playing we've had um families
playing it's been really nice to see
oh that's so cool i am kind of curious
because i have been an
imposter on my mind um are you able to
maybe
kill someone on a ladder or one of those
moving platforms or is that
off limits unfortunately it's off limits
but the fact that you thought of that
i'm like all right someone's ready
someone is just ready to kill
oh my goodness just just plopping on the
floor
off the moving platform if it happens we
know
who is sus um so i have to ask you
victoria
how much do you play among us and like i
would say a weekly basis are you like
hey man this is my work i
kind of need a timeout in my personal
life or are you just 24 7 in the game
uh yeah because it's my work i try to
separate it like i'll play it for
charity and stuff
um but the thing is is like i'm actually
a great imposter
like a forest who's our programmer
accurately called me out for being an
imposter because no one was dying
like i was too anxious to kill everyone
so so i don't really play it in my off
time but
for for work obviously i will
fair enough fair enough and speaking of
work i mean i
just have to say i feel like the team
has been
incredibly busy within the last year
how is the development team doing how
are you all doing kind of
transitioning into this high demand for
the game
yeah we are i mean one we're grateful
and excited and we wouldn't trade it for
the world or anything
but wow we are tired and anxious
it's really it's it's been really
like wild to see the reactions to it and
just like playing catch up with
everything
but with the launch of the new map and
with the account system we're like
we've kind of caught up so we're hoping
that we can get more regular updates out
and you know talk more
um but it has been a really really wild
2020 and 2021 at this rate
yeah 45 and chad says thank you to the
devs for this game
and i'm trying i'm trying to keep up
with you here chat but it's going so
fast because there is so much hype
uh to see victoria and to have you
answer questions here live on the stream
is just super cool
and to get a preview of this new map and
uh i'm sorry i just laughed at that that
murder ball animation that just happened
right there
um but yeah the airship looks super cool
as you mentioned
it's coming in what five days now um
yeah if people want to pre-order or get
their hands on any of this content or at
least
ensure that they will be getting their
hands on this content on the 31st where
can people do that
well the thing the great thing is if
you've already bought
among us whether that's on pc or mobile
um
it will automatically update it's a free
update it will be there for you on march
31st
uh and then in 2021 it'll be coming to
xbox consoles i don't have a specific
date for you yet
but that's the news
i i'm very excited about it coming to
console for
sure and with the console can you say
whether there's a cross-platform play as
well
yes yes there will be cross-platform
play because
you know you want to play with all your
friends yes
oh we love that we absolutely love that
victoria i don't know where time went
things
flew by so fast we could literally talk
to you all day long
but if anyone has any questions or wants
to know where to find you
do you have maybe a social platform that
you prefer
people to reach out on totally
yes so you can find us on twitter most
of the time so that's twitter.com
among us game you can also find us on
discord
at oh awesome
awesome well victoria thank you so much
for stopping by the id and xbox showcase
today thank you for coming by twitch
gaming and hopefully we'll see you here
soon
thank you thank you for having me and
thank you chat
oh man that was so fun i can't wait to
jump into that new map and i can't wait
to see what the new tasks are
and you know how to adjust your strategy
accordingly i saw the people in chat
saying trisha is suss
everybody always thinks i'm the imposter
even when i'm not
and i don't know why apparently i'm
super cess all the time
but you know what i'll take it i'll take
it and then we'll adjust my strategy
accordingly and uh what
what kind of imposter are you uh story
mobe
you know i like to say i'm strategic but
sometimes when that imposter title
flashes across the screen
it's like i kind of black out a little
bit maybe i get a little hungry and
crazy with power
and i'm just like yes the first person i
see oh yeah that's who i'm going for
and all my little plan just goes out the
window i panic sometimes
it's fine i try my best to have a nice
clean kill when you can like
get somebody alone and then vent out of
there real quick but it doesn't always
work that way you know sometimes you
have a kill and then
three other players walk in it gets
messed up
it's the luck of the draw sometimes but
the more clean kills the better
all right folks we have so much more
show left
today in the id at xbox showcase death's
door devs
are up next and then more exclusive
gameplay trailers
um and again just a lot more content to
show you so don't go anywhere
we will be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone welcome on back to id at
xbox showcase right here on twitch
gaming
coming up we have very special
interviews with the developers from
death's door
interviewed by stallion83 and technique
is going to be able to chat with the
developers behind 12
minutes oh this is a good show but
first uh streamer stallion83 like you
said we'll chat with the devs behind the
new game
death's door so in death story you'll be
playing as
the crow where reaping souls of the dead
is all part of an honest day's work but
the job gets lively when your assigned
soul
is stolen and you must track down a
desperate thief to a realm
untouched by death where creatures grow
far
past their expiry and overflow
with greed and power let's take a look
at this trailer now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that was very cool i'm stallion83
with me today
mark and dave and they are here to talk
about at death's
door thank you guys for joining me
thanks for having us thanks having us
yeah no problem so i want to know about
the crow
like that is he's awesome he's a badass
crow
i want to know the inspiration behind
the crow
well we thought that crows were kind of
relevant to the theme of death they're
kind of
they encapsulate the themes of the
entire game really there
it's kind of a dark kind of mysterious
bird but they're also pretty cute
and kind of funny so we decided to make
the character a crow and
as soon as we did that the game started
coming together
[Music]
really really cool so what what can you
tell us about the story
in death's door so it's set in a world
where i've got a bit of lag sorry it's
set in a world where
nothing dies naturally anymore so this
group of crows who work in this office
that we saw in the trailer
and they are in charge of reaping the
souls of the dead
and maintaining some kind of order in
this world
you obviously are one of the crows and
you get sent to a place where
nothing has died for many centuries so
as you can imagine things basically
escalate from there
very cool very cool so is this a
roguelike to me it looks like a
roguelike
or is it an rpg what type of game are we
looking at here
it's not a roguelike so it's just one
storyline that's
single player so you'll complain from
start to finish and it's like an entire
experience
and it has some light rpg elements in it
so
with the combat system you can upgrade
your things like strength and speed
and basic stats like that and you can
also find new weapons along the way
and out in the world you'll have loads
of different secrets to discover as well
so if someone wants to like 100 the game
there's like a lot
of juicy secrets in the world for them
to try and find
speaking of like 100 what are the
achievements looking like in this game
i have to ask you that question it's
mandatory nice
well yeah that's part of it because we
had so much fun making this game with so
many secrets and so much
like little touches and different things
you could do uh we had a lot of fun
coming up with the achievements as well
and probably i think one of the most fun
ones
at the very start of the game you can
actually pick up an abandoned umbrella
in this office where all the crows work
and you'll get an achievement for using
that
for every battle in the game it's
basically a very
weak weapon that is half as powerful as
any other weapon in the game so
it's a hard mode for people who want to
do that kind of thing so that might be
the most challenging achievement
that one right there may well be yeah i
haven't even attempted it myself so i
can't even comment on that
oh wow so uh with a game called death's
door
are players going to die a lot in this
game
there'll certainly be a few deaths to
have to go through yeah so
it's just is it kind of a game
it's i wouldn't say it's hard as nails
like if anyone's played our previous
game titan souls and
that would be described as probably hard
as nails but this is a bit more
forgiving a bit more accessible
but we still think it will present a
good challenge for anyone who was a fan
of the old game
yeah i think this one is certainly a
very intense action
game and it's definitely going to
challenge you but one thing that we
wanted to do this time around was create
something where
if you are hitting a wall with like a
really
ridiculously hard boss you don't just
have to keep trying over and over again
you will have
options you can do different things you
can do to prepare so
you might want to go and get more souls
which lets you upgrade your stats a bit
enhance your playstyle or you might not
want to go and search the world for
various secrets
so there's um alternate weapons that you
might feel more comfortable with
and you can also find upgrades for all
the abilities that you have access to
so yeah we want people to be able to
take different approaches and overcome
challenges in their own way
okay so what can you tell us about the
combat system and uh
how many different weapons can we use in
this game
i probably won't say the exact number of
weapons but there's a there's a few to
like change up your play style if you
want to play with more fast paced
or maybe they want to use a big heavy
weapon and
the combat was kind of inspired by games
like hyper light drifter maybe a little
bit of hotline miami it's kind of like
fast paced and you have to play quite
reactively to your surroundings like
things
can change a lot and you just have to be
on your toes all the time
and we were also really careful to make
sure that
all of the moveset that you have is very
fast very fluid
very responsive so every action you
perform it'll be executed within very
few frames of you pressing the button
so you have that kind of nice rapid
fluidity that
gives you what you need to overcome any
kind of challenge
yeah it looks incredible
um like interactions like titan swords
like pixel art kind of games and then
bring it to the 3d world as well
okay so what about replayability how
much replayability
will this game have i think
the first thing i would recommend when
when they're starting and when they
finish the game then the first thing i
would suggest
is to continue that save because we
actually let you
carry on afterwards and there is loads
of secrets someone cover in the world
loads of different things to do like we
were saying before it's a really fun one
to 100
and then beyond that then because we've
got this kind of light rpg system
you can go for a different build if you
wanted to replay it
and it does change quite a lot so you
can focus on something that's far more
speed
and magic based or something that's more
down to brute strength and range and
that kind of thing
so yeah i think that would be the the
best way to enjoy its replayability
so how many bosses we looking at we're
looking at like what is this right here
on screen
now is that a castle boss it
technically a minibus actually i mean
mini is probably not the right word for
it but
yeah so there's quite there's a few
there's a handful of uh good busted
carriers in the game
as you progress through you kind of uh
the core bosses have their own
storylines that develop and you kind of
interact with them a few times while
you're on your journey
um so by the time you get to them you
may be know about their backstory you're
going through
their area of the world which is kind of
they've
left their mark on the world yeah we
really want to show
how these bosses have adapted to the
strange situation that's going on in
this world
and how they've become these like overly
powerful beings
and like mark would say and how they've
affected the world around them so
there's a lot of kind of each chapter of
the game has a bit of
build up learning about this boss
potentially even meeting them
and then when you do get to the bosses
it's like a culmination of that chapter
and our opportunity to up everything to
11 basically cool
so um when can uh players get their
hands on this game when is this coming
out
we're actually pretty far along with it
we're we're almost
content complete we're just polishing
and we're fixing bugs
and so we're hoping to launch this
summer
awesome man that sounds great um what
about like dlc you guys got anything
planned for dlc down the line
sorry yeah we're focusing on making sure
that the um core experience is
a full satisfying thing where you know
if you want to explore when you're
playing the game you know that
that world is entirely realized there's
nothing we're waiting to add later
so we're we're focusing on the core
single player
narrative experience for now and then
yeah maybe we'll consider other things
after
so if uh fans want to follow you know
more information about this game where
can they where can they find the updates
for this
and they should follow us on twitter at
acid nerve
and we'll be sure to keep everyone
updated so you you're just two guys
ready
two guys make this game is that correct
um we handle quite a lot between us but
we also have
an art team so we have this awesome team
of a couple of concept artists and a 3d
modeler
who work with us as well so it's them
who've created all of the assets that we
need to
bring our ideas to life but yeah we we
wear quite a lot of hats between the two
of us as well it's quite a
quite a good collaborative project where
everyone has a lot of creative input
okay that's awesome so the noir world
when it when the trailer starts out
are we gonna be in in the game in in
that or was that just for the trailer
is that like the hub or something yeah
that's like
the axe is a hub world so as you
progress through the game which is one
like consistent open world to explore
and you'll find these
like key holes which you can unlock when
they kind of introduce shortcuts back
into this
hub world so the actual main world is
like this color um
overgrown like interesting place then
there's the office where the reapers
work which is kind of a
noise kind of depressing bureaucratic
environment
yeah and the trailer i saw like uh tombs
floating
what's what's in the tombs
uh they were probably the doors so oh
the doors where
the place of the crows work yeah it's
called the hall of doors
so basically the way that the the crows
do their job of reaping souls
they have these doors which can lead
them to any place so
that's how it functions as a hook you
can use the doors to travel
via shortcuts to back anywhere else in
the world where you were before
okay well thank you guys for your time i
appreciate it and uh
we're kicking it back thank you guys so
much for joining us
thanks oh death's door
these look good now i do want to say
first you know shout out to all of all
of the developers but
especially these smaller studios my
goodness
i mean they were even saying between the
two of them how many different hats
and how many different roles and
responsibilities they have to
create these amazing games to so shout
out to all of you because oh my gosh i
can
only imagine how hard of a job that is
so much yeah just a team of two way to
go mark and david love to see it and
chad was
really loving this one i'm i was trying
to pull comments out as we go i saw
monkey dwallaces for real instant bye
i am orvina's uh i'm sorry if i said
your name wrong said
devs made a really great game love the
dark mood gg
and uh tons of love in chat for the
black and white
atmosphere when we saw kind of the black
and white atmospheric scenes and
i definitely want to know more about
this world that they're fleshing out i
think it
really really looks cool i even saw some
people in chat saying
uh potential future game of the year
so definitely loving that
again way to go team of two mark and
david yes
for sure up next everyone oh i'm i'm
excited about this
have you ever wondered what it would be
like battling
dinosaurs with guns or are you hoping to
learn
what kind of weapons you'll get to use
in stalker
2. our next batch of trailers will
provide many exciting updates to games
we're all
dying to play i see you guys in the chat
moving
let's take a look at some more new
gameplay
trailers here we go
[Music]
locked and loaded
hanging the area
for the weak points
this is where the fun begins
[Music]
here
we took care of the world because no one
else
would we thought we could keep
everything safe protect everything that
mattered
and we were wrong
what was the difference between the
people on the inside or the outside
neither of them gave a damn about the
beings that power our way of life
trespasses are the same murdering
living creatures for a tiny piece
[Music]
we are the caretakers
[Music]
and sunsoft present the final piece of a
trilogy
[Music]
a metal attacker embarks on a brand new
adventure
the side view and top-down action is
more intense than
ever before
jason's third battle against mutant kind
is about to begin
what new threats await him in a new
dimension
[Music]
the pinnacle of mutant blasting action
is
here blaster master zero three
a new chapter in blaster master history
unfolds july 29 2021
nt creates
[Music]
hi my name is zack and i'm in charge of
pr at gc game world
we made the original stalker trilogy and
now we are developing stall cartoon
the 23rd of march marked the anniversary
of the first game in the series
stalker shadowster novel celebrating the
date
last year we released the first
in-engine screenshot of stalker 2
followed by the first trailer and the
gameplay teaser
that was our way to celebrate 25 years
of making games
here at gc game world
this year we have an anniversary gift
for our fans as well
it's an update on stalker 2. it's not as
big
as a new trailer just yet but we hope
you will enjoy it let's start with
something familiar
yet completely renewed
and here is the first look at the
updated costumes
the zone is a dangerous place so it's
filled with different factions
the freedom and the duty are two iconic
opposing forces
first ones see the zone as a free
ever-growing state
while the second ones would eagerly
sacrifice their lives
to prevent it spreading these ideologies
will never meet the agreement
as you may have guessed you will see
them in the sequel
the recognizable design for each faction
has been enriched with details
if you look closely you can see scuffs
scratches
and sticking out threads
please keep in mind the models are still
work in progress
the time has passed and the new forces
emerged in the zone
you can expect to see more factions in
stalker 2.
let's move on the reception of stalker 2
has been extremely positive so far and
we are truly grateful for that
thank you for your passion and your
interest
stalker 2 is a shooter game and you
can't imagine it without the guns right
here are a couple of guns you will see
in the game
the arsenal will include more than 30
different weapons
of course there will be lots of
modifications for each gun
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
finally let's finish with something
completely unexpected
we work a lot to fill the world with a
decent amount of memorable details
and sometimes it takes us to completely
unexpected grounds
can you see this guy quite a charmer if
you ask me
but let's take a closer look at his
teeth
[Music]
and the tooth is gone or changed
or replaced with a dental crown
[Music]
all made with our custom tees tool one
of the many plugins we use in the
development process
for specific changes like that these
tiny accents
ensure each character looks completely
unique
literally every human in stalker 2 has
one of a kind smile
or green i suppose and that covers up
our news for today please subscribe to
our official social channels to receive
up-to-date info
about the game or ask any questions we
would be pleased to share more about
stalker 2
including gameplay demonstration later
this year
until then good hunting stalkers
[Music]
my gosh i mean there was so much
hype in the chat for soccer too i mean
wow
i'm i'm blown away for those to be a
work in progress
they were so detailed my gosh
what did you think about that trisha
yeah i mean hyper realism so thank you
zach
for that update on stalker 2 i saw a lot
of support in chat
for the dev team a lot of love like you
said brianna for this game
the updated costumes look super
realistic and fantastic uh we got an
in-depth look at some of those weapons
and that tooth customization oh super
super realistic and definitely
unexpected for me i saw six six seven
dlos in chat says these graphics are so
dope
wtf sexy headphones which i love your
name your twitch name okay absolutely
cannot wait to play this game
yet i hope that the devs take all the
time they need to make it right so
absolutely i saw a couple people in chat
saying like take your time let's make
this the best game ever
and uh yeah it was cool that zach was
able to stop by
and show us that update of what they
have so far for stalker 2.
absolutely and i love what you said too
i feel like it is so
important to give developers the time
that they need
to push these games out and allow them
to do them properly
i know there's so much hype behind so
many different games but
developers are people too they need some
time they need to take the rest that
they need
give them some time and don't worry you
guys will be happy just a little bit of
patience
i you know i'm always a fan i will be
patient and i will wait for the game to
be awesome so again thank you zach for
that update
uh up next streamer technique we'll sit
down
with director louis antonio about his
new game
12 minutes an interactive thriller about
a man
trapped in a time loop let's take a look
at that trailer now
all right close your eyes i want you to
think of a flower
look at its contours its curves
now i want you to imagine it
repeat these phrases may you be free
from
suffering may you be free from fear
may you know peace and joy
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back and imagine
being stuck in a
thriller-themed 12-minute time loop over
and over again to figure out
what's going on in your life well today
i have the pleasure
to bring in luis the director of 12
minutes
joining me here as technique as you guys
know uh luis
i am this game when i first saw it
at e3 uh i was just like what is this
and what's happening because it reminded
me of an old movie called butterfly
effect
long time ago i remember seeing it when
i was younger and it
blew my mind can you introduce yourself
and tell the child a little bit about
yourself and about this game 12 minutes
a technique um yeah definitely so 12
minutes
is um yeah it's an interactive thriller
about a man trapped in a time loop
um the whole game happens inside an
apartment
you come home from work you're having an
evening with your wife then this this
guy shows up
he um he accuses your wife of murder and
then
um he attacks you you pass out and then
you go back to the start of the evening
and then you have to use the knowledge
that you accumulate every loop to try to
change the outcome
and hopefully break the loop it all
happens inside the apartment
it's all in real time and the game
doesn't really tell you what to do right
so it's
kind of up to you to decide what to do
based on what you experience
i love that that it seems there's so
many setups for
failures and maybe one success um but
before we get into the all the
complications of the game
we have to know and i'm pretty sure you
got hit with this question
when is the game going to be ready
because we are ready to get our hands on
this
and experience 12 minutes and find out
how
to overcome this loop
um so the game we're the final stage
like final final stages we're doing qa
polishing a lot of play testing making
sure that the game is really smooth
finalizing the music it's going to come
out soon very very soon um
definitely this year the exact date we
don't know yet
but once we do we're gonna we're gonna
announce it and
it's happening it's definitely happening
we believe you i
i could see the progress over the years
for sure um
but we can't talk about the game without
going into a little bit more detail
about this is a
cinematic thriller so to speak and it's
very interactive so the most important
key
components of this is your cast and and
and
the voiceovers and the narrator could
you go in a little bit uh
more detail about that yes so the the
whole experience because the game never
really tells you
what you should be doing it's a bit
about how you interpret what's happening
and so it's a very personal
um intimate environment where it's you
with these
three other characters i mean two other
characters and um
and yeah so the voice acting is there to
really help um
like you you gotta connect with these
characters and care about what's
happening in order to
to um to be able to follow the story and
see where it leads
that's a very very important factor is
connecting with the characters and
and finding some kind of relatability to
feel the emotion that your main
character feels or main characters i
should say
um and and talking about relate
relatability
everything happens into an apartment so
the control aspect of this game has to
be very important so what kind of
controls
can we look forward to the accessibility
of controls in the system
um so for 12 minutes i wanted to uh
it's kind of a point and click game but
a bit cleaner than the old ones where
you you never quite know what's going to
happen you you have objects in the
apartment like
on the trailer you can see you picked up
a knife there could be a mug there's the
plates
so anything you can pick up you can
combine with other characters or with
yourself
and then there's things you can like
open the door close the door and
it might seem that it's not that many uh
interactions but each one
the characters react to everything you
do so very quickly it branches out
into many possibilities oh that's
amazing yeah i saw
a tiny bit of the gameplay through the
trailer it seemed like
uh the stuff that you do pick up have
everything has a consequence it seems
and uh
it's kind of like a risk reward system
uh you know like
eating dinner uh what if you pick up a
knife and and you try to go after the
guy that comes in an apartment you might
have a consequence of that
that's really really cool um i would
love to do more into the story narrative
in the characters now you have a
i'm guessing that's her husband that
comes home
to see his wife and they're going to
have a nice dinner and somebody's going
to come by at some point and accuse her
of murder
is there anything else you could tell us
about that like i mean does the husband
not know about the murder like what's
going on
is that both shocked
yeah i don't want to say much because
it's um right everything you learn
will affect how you how you deal with
the situation so there's not much that
can be
that can be shared um
yeah that's a tricky question there's
really not much i can tell about the
story like i i want players really to go
in
and and um right and have a blank slate
in how they're going to interpret the
situation
but it's pretty don't have an open mind
pretty much is how you need to play this
game i'm assuming right
yeah like the like the situations that
you're going to go through
uh none of them there's no no there's no
right or wrong right for example let's
say the cop comes in
and he starts attacking you right you
could try to fight or not fight but each
each each option that you choose will
branch out in a different direction so
you're always learning
and you will use that knowledge and the
character also learns everything that
you've done and
you're gonna try to use that in order to
try to change the outcome so
having a blank slate is is is pretty
good for the player i think
um absolutely absolutely a lot of these
a lot of games like this do have
a lot of mind tricks involved but
speaking of gameplay and keeping your
mind open
how the length of the game i'm pretty
sure people are going to be like okay i
understand
this this game is called 12 minutes is
the game actually 12 minutes can you
expand on the length of the game and
give us a little insight on that
definitely um so the loop lasts 12
minutes
um but for example when the cop comes in
it's about three minutes into the loop
so if this was groundhog day the film is
like bill murray was dying at breakfast
so once you actually
managed to to to survive the cup
the loop still continues um from play
testing we
i thought the game would last about
eight hours but so far we
were rounding up to 15 to 18 hours so it
goes pretty deep
um until you reach what i would call a
satisfactory ending
man 20 18 you're getting on that 20 hour
mark and i
wouldn't even i believe in my head that
was gonna be that long of his experience
that's really great
um this is a single player experience
right this is no multiplayer or nothing
like that it's completely single player
yeah yeah it's a single player okay so
single player experience uh what about
replayability once let's say you solve
the loop
uh what is there to do afterwards what
do we have to look forward to
um so yeah
i think once you play through uh you're
gonna have your own experience i think a
lot of it will be
talking with your friends and other
players about the interpretations of
what's happening and how to
how they dealt with the situation or
whatever branches they went through
um but yeah this is i will
my goal with this was to make something
that's very clean uh no fat
and very um really respecting the
player's time so yeah you play once you
enjoy this
and and then you're done it's not like
those games you keep playing over and
over
you know i respect that so much uh just
looking at it it seems like you're just
thrown
automatically into the action of it
you're there is no
like overall huge arcing story that you
have to sit and wait a couple hours
before you get to the game play
i really
[Music]
i um yeah i partnered with tena putin
interactive
and that's when we we kind of managed to
bring the voice cast in and really
take this to another all new level
wow that's the lighting the atmosphere
you really hit on that thriller it seems
like it starts off all peaceful and then
things get chaotic
and then out of nowhere all the rooms in
the apartment
uh well first of all in all the rooms in
the apartment itself i'm going
thinking you start on an elevator or
maybe you like come into your
hallway are the rooms available to go
into or is only your apartment and if
it's in your apartment can you go into
every room and interact with most things
in your apartment
yeah so the whole game what you see the
moment the game starts will be what
you're gonna have when the game ends
nothing else will change apart from your
knowledge of everything that's happening
in there
um yeah you can go to all rooms you can
interact with everything and yeah if
you've played before and you start again
you have a lot more knowledge on how to
deal with the situation and and handle
things differently
and i would say also like um the reason
why it's so small and so tiny
is actually to allow your actions to
have very clear outcomes
you know like if you imagine loop was 24
hours you'd get lost about doing
a bunch of things in sequence in order
to know what was going to happen but by
compressing the experience to this level
right if i lock the door i know that
maybe the cop won't be able to get in or
maybe he'll do something else
and in a minute you're back at the start
and you can very quickly see the outcome
of your actions uh
and makes it pretty intense too it seems
like a lot of thought process has been
put into the game and i really like that
feature as well
of not giving us too big of a loop so we
can just really hone in because a lot of
games especially rpgs give you so much
information in the beginning
reading all this stuff and you tend to
forget the the core
product of the game itself so having us
in that loop
is a very very good idea um
are there multiple endings uh you know
i'm not asking for details
you know i just want to know you could
solve a loop one way but is there
multiple ways to solve it
so when i started to work on this game
right that question kept coming up
i kept asking myself how do you when the
story that keeps repeating itself
um so the answer is there is
what you can call a conclusion but it
doesn't match what you'd expect out of a
linear experience right when you see a
movie you get to the end you get the
credits
but this is interactive and you can
participate so
what we call an ending is slightly
different from
what usually movies do so you will reach
a satisfactory conclusion
i think uh what that is and how that is
it's kind of different from
people usually expecting games that's
amazing lewis i have to ask
this concept is something that we don't
see often in video games were there any
inspiration that led to
creating this game you said about two to
three years ago you started it did you
have any kind of inspiration behind it
that um that could lead into maybe even
more
titles like this um so early on i i
there were some pillars that i wanted to
work on like i've been working in games
for many years uh i've been at rockstar
ubisoft working on the witness with
jonathan blow and always as an artist i
was always on the artist side of things
and
and this idea of repeating the same
amount of time over and over which games
do naturally
you know what if that repetition was
actually something you were aware of
right rather than
tomb raider you die you reset and you're
doing the same thing but no one
acknowledges what's happening um so
along with this
i wanted also to kind of um
take things from the movie industry like
from the cinematic side of things you
know like for example like
hitchcock rear window the way you spend
the whole movie
sitting in the balcony and interpreting
what's happening or like in memento
where nolan
changed the order of the scene so that
the player feels what the character is
going through right
and as i started to learn to program and
make the game i realize that we do have
these tools as a game designers and we
we can bring them in you know how how
you interact with the environment how
much information we give you how
the world reacts to you so it was slowly
each element i would bring in i would
see is this element
in the same language that i and then the
same theme and message i'm trying to
convey if yes it goes in
if not i would take it out so then
slowly these things start to grow into
into 12 minutes wow so
that's that's really cool we really
don't in chat i just want you to
understand we don't get to hear the side
of development right
we get to see the game or we're like oh
this is cool this looks beautiful when
it's on the other
but it seems like lucy you have a like a
almost like a uh
a movie direction or a cinematic
background
and be able to be able to lay out a game
and you were just doing art side of
stuff i'm pretty sure you took a lot of
those tools that you got from all those
other developers and brought it into
making your own
do do you see yourself making more
titles with more cinematic approach
because i think this is a wonderful
avenue
that a lot of games typically just throw
for cut scenes and not really give us
the player experience
in yeah i mean i i wouldn't call it
cinema i
i think it's cinematic but i would call
it um
i think it's like the the history of
games has this background of you know
you have
levels you have objectives you have
coins and goals i'm like what if we
bring
some aspects of it but not others and
and i think
for this specific experience i think
being cinematic and and
and bringing a lot of cues you know from
from films about the way the actors move
the way they talk to each other the
tempo and everything makes sense
um and i would like to keep doing that
for sure um
but if the next titles would be similar
i don't know but i think this this idea
of really paying attention to the
elements we bring in like
for example the top down the main reason
for being top down is
so that you can you can easily navigate
in the environment
right if you bring first person suddenly
eighty percent of the people cannot play
the game because they don't know how to
control the character but
i realize that if you just click where
you go and then when when you go into an
object like the fridge
it goes into first person and out you
you keep having all the verbs you would
have
in other video games but the simplicity
is there so someone who doesn't play
video games can just jump in as long as
you know how to
click where you want to go to it just
works
and there's no compromise in the design
complexity
i can pick your brain all day you you
just see him have an answer for
everything i love it
wow that is just amazing so the funny
thing is i love how you chose i was
thinking about the accessibility and
what you were saying because i was like
yeah
um us video gamers going to be a lot of
people going to just be like
why point-and-click where we can
experience this a little bit more in
depth but
i also love the fact that you went
point-and-click for the simple fact
of you get to see the environment that
you're in and it kind of builds a kind
of tense
intenseness to it as well like when you
hit your first loop or your second loop
you know this guy is coming
what do you do where do you go you know
and being in first person you kind of
panic and you lose a lot of that
atmosphere effect um being able to go
into rooms locked doors
and and pick apart certain mental
puzzles i i should say to to fix it now
i really want to know about
before we let you go today i really want
to know about the characters because
they're the most important key opponents
components of this game right now
especially the main character that you
play
does this attitude change through the
loops or do you kind of have like a more
of a monotone
feel does he start to realize that he's
in a loop and he's like oh my god and
gets frantic or the choices that you
make
conversation wise get a little bit more
tense or
zooming yeah so that's a really good
question so early on i kept
asking myself how am i going to convey
the progress of the character if
everything is reset
right i cannot change his clothes i
cannot change
nothing can change everything goes back
to the start but his knowledge stays so
so the idea is that every time that that
you
that you loop uh he hopefully he will
do this journey with you i i we try to
read the frustrations you're going
through and he will react those
frustrations and
everything that you make him do he's
going to be aware so for example when
you go talk with the wife
everything you know is what you will um
yeah every time every loop you do
everything you do he will know it and be
able to talk
and execute on in the next loop or if
you make him do things that he doesn't
feel very comfortable the more he makes
them
the more comfortable he will be making
them so he evolves next to you
and you'll see that evolution the way he
talks with the wife like
the first time maybe he's very excited
to see her by luke 50 he's like hey how
are you what's your day no no no no no
you see that evolution put that realism
in it yeah yeah and
we something else we realize is by being
top down you don't see the faces
and by not seeing the faces first we
don't go into this technical challenge
of rendering faces
but suddenly the body movement and the
voice acting
they elevate the experience because
you're you're kind of projecting
what they're saying to each other
because you don't see exactly what the
faces are doing and it really helps
keep this intensity
i love it the animation is going to be a
key part if everyone in chat wants more
12 minutes i could talk to him all day
but unfortunately i'm gonna take up the
whole show and we're not supposed to do
that
so anyway louis thank you so very much
for being here but before you go my
friend please
tell them where they can find you the
game and every information possible to
be able to
experience 12 minutes uh so yes you can
go to 12minutesgame.com
that's the website there's a development
blog that i've been writing for like
five years now you can
if you feel like you can see the
progress of the game uh
that's what i'm going to announce when
we we're at a release date and i'm
always
posting stuff you can follow the game on
twitter at 12 minutes game
or follow me at [ __ ] electric also on
twitter
but just type 12 minutes again on google
and you get all these links
boom 12 minutes thank you so very much
for joining us and
chat i would love to stay with you but i
gotta go and send it back to story mode
bay and trisha thank you for
your time thank you
take my thank you technique and louis uh
i don't know about you brianna but 12
minutes has been on my radar
for a while now i want to say it was
maybe a couple e3s ago
maybe they first kind of showed us a
look at it but having that really like
top-down very personal and intimate
viewpoint on it
plus the intensity of the emotions of
what's going on in the loop i just think
it's a super super
cool concept has this one on your radar
too
yes and it looks amazing this is exactly
the type of game that i have been
waiting for um
i definitely love to see so much hype
coming in from the chat
especially because the concept of the
game is so brand new and different
normally i feel like people would be a
little bit apprehensive like a top-down
view of the entire game
i don't know but there was so much hype
and
i understand completely like i said take
my money
take my credit card right now like i am
buying it day one
no questions asked oh yeah a lot of
people in chat saying buying day one i
saw that silky c
said i want to play this game so bad it
looks so good and the cost sense the
concept is so fascinating
um amayas94 said concept sounds amazing
well done guys instead 93 so the art
design is so beautiful and clean
uh so a lot to love with 12 minutes but
we have so many other things still to
cover next up we have another exciting
game from annapurna interactive to
announce
last stop but rather than show you a
quick trailer the team at annapurna
interactive were nice enough to send
along an
exclusive gameplay demo so after that we
will then meet the creators of the game
astra ascending so right now let's take
a look
hello and welcome to last stop a new
game from variable state
and annapurna interactive last stop is a
story driven adventure game
where you navigate through three
entangled stories that intertwine into
one
wild sci-fi adventure full of mystery
wonder
and danger today we're going to show you
how this game works by playing a quick
sequence from one of these stories
in this tale two neighbors john and jack
have accidentally swapped bodies in a
freak accident
they must now help each other blend in
as they try and find a way to get back
to their old bodies
and way of life let's take a look at how
you could play this out
[Music]
so where do you work superfan it's not
far from your office actually
and people pay you to do this yeah
some people say game makers are the new
rock stars dad
[Music]
i struggle enough with the oven timer i
don't think this is gonna work
don't sweat it i'll walk you through it
think of me as a master puppeteer and
knew my obedient marionette
don't forget i need to be taken to
school at
some point yeah yeah now first you need
to find my desk
you can't miss it it's the one with the
robot doing the sick dab
sneak past sonia the receptionist avoid
any awkward questions
she's a bit dippy so you shouldn't have
any problems there
she didn't sound that dippy on the phone
your mean
chat
[Music]
[Music]
hello stranger
you look well rested
slept the whole week and anyway i should
probably just get going
someone's in a hurry get in there jack
my son
good morning derek's in a good mood
who the hell was that what
jack sure you're not still feeling ill
he's my boss yeah
so what do i do when i get there
it's monday that means sprint planning
you're going to coordinate with your
team on their tests for the week
that's not good do stuff like that
molly's right i don't think anyone would
follow me into battle
it's simple trust me joan's working on
modelling the last of the cream cakes
for mrs clapton's tea shop
leticia is putting the finishing touches
to the ai for the retirement home scene
with the shell shock veteran
tobias is writing up the design for the
interactive funeral procession
admire is midway through implementing
rumble support jonah cakes
leticia shellshock tobias funerals maya
rumble
see you're a natural
[Music]
uh hello um
[Music]
good weekends everyone go to anything
interesting
no okay let's see
so i'm supposed to go around everyone
and check what you're all working on
so um jonah
you are modeling cream cakes aren't you
i'll take the silence as an agreement
okay
leticia
you're doing something with ai no no i a
for retirement homes yeah that sounds
right
okay tobias
are you rumbling actually i'm not sure
that's right
and finally maya
are you doing the ia the ai
one of them sorry i'm not sure that's
quite right
look even i can tell this meeting is a
bit pointless
you all know what you're up to even if i
don't
i guess what you're really looking for
is a pep talk isn't it some words of
encouragement
i'm sorry i thought i could do this
but none of this comes naturally to me
you all look like nice bright people you
don't need to listen to an old fart like
me
i'm sorry that i can't give you anything
more inspiring
maybe i'll just leave you with the
advice that my dad gave to me on my 18th
birthday
keep your head down don't take
unnecessary risks
stay out of debt
cheers and that's just a quick look at
last stop
be sure to check out more updates soon
as for game rise to console
and pc this year thanks for stopping by
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
oh man how awkward was that poor meeting
in the last stop trailer like i
i felt it in my soul brianna
how awkward it was for that guy what do
you think i mean
you know what i really appreciated that
for last stop
they gave us a demo i feel like so often
with gameplay trailers
you don't really know what's going on or
sometimes
the trailer doesn't really reflect how
the actual gameplay is
so big shout out to them i am very
excited for it but i'm also
very excited for this next section
coming up
now we've learned so much today about
unique indie titles that are coming to
xbox soon
but we know what you guys are wondering
at home myself included
what games are coming to game pass well
i think we have the answer for you let's
take a look
a tiger
stop dancing and get to it
is
come on
[Music]
all they can do is just watch me climb
higher
they can't stop they can't stop my can
do is
[Music]
play
[Music]
[Music]
there's
[Music]
game pass hype so many great games
coming to game pass i mean like
i'm trying to keep track of them all but
they were flying at me so fast celeste
wilde at heart nobody saves the world
the ascent and for everyone who's been
asking for it in chat library of
is it ruina aruna i know i'm going to
say it wrong but yes coming to
game pass which is super exciting game
pass is so dope
harrison ave i see you there in chat um
but yeah
so we've seen a lot of great games today
we've seen a lot of teases
uh and of course super hyped brianna and
i are both super hyped about what is
coming to game pass but
uh i just want to take a moment to thank
everybody
who's joined on the show today we had
chris charla from id
at xbox earlier victoria tran from inner
sloth
for among us gwen and trina we're here
to talk about from chicane club to talk
about soup pot
lewis was here just recently to talk
about 12 minutes graham and ian talking
about nobody saves the world which was
awesome from drink box studios
zach and lou were from bunny hug and
they were here talking about moon glow
bay mark and david we're here from acid
nerve talking about death's door
and of course a huge thank you to all of
our uh streamer friends and guest hosts
who are here today
kate stark stallion83 danitaj technique
and blind gamer steve
you guys were all awesome and uh brianna
and i literally couldn't have done the
show and shown you all of these
wonderful eye
uh indie games without you so uh
yeah brianna how you feeling oh my gosh
i can't believe we're at the end of our
show this was
so amazing to be a part of and co-host
with you
um i do want to take a minute to shout
out to production
for holding it down behind the scenes i
know it is not easy putting these shows
together
and getting everyone in their right
places where they need to be
so thank you we do appreciate you now if
anyone's you know looking for me on the
internet uh my name is storymodebay you
can find me on twitch twitter
instagram ticktalk if you're into that
sort of thing come by and say hi
i promise i don't bite it all now trisha
where can everyone find you
uh if people want to find me on socials
on twitter instagram
uh etc it's that girl trish with no i in
the girls so just that grltrish
or right here on twitch you can find me
at trisha hershberger just my name it's
like right
yeah right there but this has been so
much fun uh if you are an indie games
fan i do an indie game showcase on my
channel every tuesday
uh but you can expect to see lots of
triple a's and stuff on my channel as
well but we have a real good time
stop on by and say hi to the dragon
rider army and uh thank you
to everybody who's been here in chat
who's been commenting we
see you uh thank you just for
participating in the show and also shout
out to anyone
co-streaming this event today i know all
the things here on twitch gaming uh
are co-streamable so to all my
co-streamers out there
what's up and thank you so again just
thanks to everyone who is part of the
showcase today i hope you found a new
indie game to fall in love with
and we'll see you soon with more great
con content here on twitch gaming thanks
everybody
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]